you
you
hey everybody another day another
briefing another day with significantly
more new coronavirus cases than any
prior day at least in the United States
there are starting to be some may be
okay numbers out of Italy and I'm going
to get to that in a little bit but I
also want to make sure that we don't
miss what what appears to be now a
posturing from the Trump administration
that we already should be looking at
loosening things now understand how
crazy this is in states that were early
like here in Massachusetts we are sort
of on day eight nine kind of right we
are maybe starting to get close to
seeing some improvement in the numbers
and again we still may be very far from
that half the country hasn't done a damn
thing yet half the country doesn't even
think there's anything that they should
be doing because governors have not been
doing the right thing and Trump is
already starting to tease this idea and
we'll look at in fact I think I have his
tweets ready here already let me see
here Donald Trump tweeting last night
and retweeting himself we cannot let the
cure be worse than the problem itself at
the end of the 15 day period we will
make a decision as to which way we want
to go look at these lunatics we have
complete faith in you making the right
decision mr. president correct
15 days then we keep the high-risk
groups protected yes we need to return
to work oh my god it's Joey salads
imagine so these people have no idea
what's going on and as I tweeted when
was it I think it was earlier today
Larry Kudlow who is the often seemingly
drunk Trump economic advisor he now is
starting to repeat the same thing so
there they're getting us ready for
starting to undo things before we even
make any progress
Governor Cuomo said much the same a
minute ago he said we got to plan the
pivot open the valve how do you do that
where we're gonna have to try to do that
we can't shut in the economy the
economic cost to individuals is just too
great so let's see how this thing plays
out
more tests oh but the president is right
sorry oh great so let's see how this
thing plays out more testing is
essential and we're loading up with
tests now that's going to be a big help
but the president is right the cure
can't be worse than the disease and
we're going to have to make some
difficult trade-offs I'm not the spoke
to I don't want to get ahead of the
story I spoke to the president about
this very subject late last day you guys
get it right I mean they're starting to
basically say hey guys we're gonna trade
some deaths for getting the economy
going and we're gonna trade overwhelming
the medical system and you only have to
look at Italy to see how that goes they
have churches filled with caskets right
that that's what the and and patients
who need ventilators and can't get them
and decisions having to be made that
that are really horrible horrible
decisions so that's the direction that
clearly they are going in and we will
see whether Donald Trump or anybody can
talk him out of it there's an
interesting interview that was done with
dr. Anthony Fauci where Anthony foul she
was asked you know Trump seems to be
lying like all the time and and you seem
to know that he's lying can't you you
know correct him and he said what do you
expect me to do you know I can't fight
with the president every time he lies
essentially and foul Chi being put in an
impossible position and by the way foul
she's almost 80 years old and in a very
very high-risk group and he's out there
having to deal with Donald Trump's lies
so it's very very very ugly stuff if
you're just joining us YouTube Twitter
twitch and Facebook live welcome I
really appreciate that you guys are here
once again we are as far as we know 18
minutes from the start of today's press
briefing hopefully there will be more
doctors today in the press briefing than
than politicians and they have been
running very very late so we may have
some time to talk about things here
which I appreciate having time to talk
about with you because there is so much
to discuss let me thank a few people
Zach Bushman has just grabbed a
membership at join pakman.com Thank You
Zach also want to say thanks to
Christian Eriksen whose new member
number two today at join pakman.com
consider grabbing a subscription to
support the feed also want to address a
few super chats that are starting to
come in John Howell says instead our
communication devices stopped breaking
coconuts the sweet meat inside now
connected became the coconut cosmic dot
era I don't know what that is I have no
clue what that means whatsoever but I
appreciate the $20 in support John I
also want to say thanks to you Chet
peoples and Donna Williams for firt for
their contributions as well if you have
anything you want me to address or
answer feel free to use that super chat
function over on Twitch you can do much
the same wheel poi says with their
twitch Prime subscription stay safe
that's what I'm doing I'm barely leaving
leaving my house and eggs 66 has also
subscribed with twitch prime ok people
have been asking me if I've been making
any financial moves now who cares what I
do right I'm not I'm no expert and
certainly I don't want to give financial
advice but I'll tell you what I've done
so far throughout this entire thing
financially one thing is I've moved as
people know I own very few stocks I just
don't think I'm good at picking stocks
so I don't do it I just buy index funds
I've been doing it for 15 years that's
really all I do one of the things I did
is I was a little bit over exposed to
the US market and not enough
internationally so at the beginning of
this a couple weeks ago I did move some
money from u.s. total stock market index
to international to sort of be you know
if other countries start to figure this
out and the US doesn't I want to be a
little more exposed internationally and
a little less so to the US I did up my
Bitcoin a little bit and listen again I
don't know what the I'm doing right I'm
just thinking maybe Bitcoin might be a
hedge in some way it may not it may just
move in parallel with the market so I
expanded my Bitcoin a little bit and
then I did buy I did buy for
different stocks let's just see how they
did today I bought Live Nation and the
reason I did that is I felt that oh wow
it's a up 10% today even though the
market was down my thought was that the
big decline that we've seen because
obviously live events nothing is
happening for now my thought is
eventually live events will be a thing
and I sort of considered it to be at a
discount okay so I bought Live Nation
none of this is financial advice okay
everybody has to figure out what makes
sense for them I did by Bayer babe Avery
this is it right here and the reason I
did this is it's basically a chloroquine
moon shot it's they are one of the main
manufacturers of chloroquine which may
possibly be a treatment it may not we're
getting some horrible side effects
reports as well from doctors in
California I bought some Bayer my
thought was worst case it'll recover
when everything else does I bought Roku
the idea being like Netflix Wow up 20%
today that's nuts
the idea being Roku might do well
because people are stuck at home
watching stuff so I bought Roku and then
lastly I did buy zoom now importantly
zoom is ZM and that was up 24
interesting of 20% today I bought zoom
under the idea that a lot of people are
going to be working from home now hilari
hilariously or not a lot of people
believe that zooms a Z oom is the zoom
people are trying to buy but zoom
technologies is a random company and
they're down 50% today why people
thought last week they were buying zoom
video conferencing when they bought this
and it went crazy over the weekend
everybody realized this is the wrong
thing and so now it has crashed 50% so
the act if you're trying to buy zoom
that we are all using for conferences
its ZM okay zoom video communications
that's the one that you you should be
looking at and of course I'm not telling
you you should be looking at that I am
merely telling you that the moves that I
made on the basis that maybe there's
some way to salvage
appears to be increasingly a sort of
great depression situation let me say
thanks to a few other folks who just
signed up at join pakman.com ullis
Seanie is new member number 3 at join
pakman.com and chris man is new member
number 4 today at join pakman.com really
appreciate that if you're just joining
us on youtube remember to hit like and
subscribe very very important like and
subscribe really does help us out big
time
okay other super chats coming in let me
see here thanks to jamal swift who says
hey homie hey Jamal great to see you all
Lisa surprised POTUS and VP are together
on crowded stage listen the disease is
getting very close to these guys
Trump's been tested pence and his wife
have been tested Rand Paul has it Mitt
Romney's in quarantine a lot of these
folks have been exposed and and and it
is surprising Jason the ex has grabbed a
youtube subscription Ren Holder says I
don't think I can listen to Trump ramble
on again yeah if you have to tune out
when Trump starts just hang until then
and I'll be answering questions and
going over a few other things Chris Emma
says Trump's reaction to Romney
Quarantine spoke volumes yeah let's look
at that while we're at it we have time
this was let's see where was that Romney
here is Trump's reaction to finding out
Mitt Romney is in a quarantine take a
listen to this also two of them weren't
contact with Ricky's trying out with the
critical stimulus package vote expect
Romney's imagination yes gee that's too
bad
so that is sarcasm and kind of you know
making a joke of it and he's just a
terrible person you and I if you were
watching yesterday with me we saw that
happen live and it was it was pretty
sick pretty sick I'll tell you Danny
Thompson says amy klobuchar husband
tested positive and is in the hospital
but not needing a ventilator
Amy not to be tested as she has not seen
her husband for 14 days Wow baby grib
says do you think today's briefing is
just the same old dog and pony show you
never know there are briefings where you
have actual doctors who say important
things and then you have briefings where
it's just Trump basically bragging about
how much of a genius he is you never
know which one it's going to be Beezus
see Christ says the University of
Arizona uses zoom not bad stuff I've
been using it to chat with friends
primarily Timothy s says [ __ ] has hit
the fan here in Dallas I'm a pediatric
behavioral therapist today we made a
list of all clients who need therapy to
cancel everyone else yeah that's I got a
phone I have a new I'm switching doctor
soon to one that lives near near me or
one whose office is close to where I
live and I was told it canceled until
further notice if you need something
urgently you can call but it's not I
don't it's already been rescheduled
twice now and you know we'll we'll see
what happens there Alex Jones says
Stephen Kenneth bunnell the second says
he hates Kyle kolinsky
he called Bernie supporters chills and
idiots why is he jealous of more
successful progressive commentators I
have no idea the stakes are too high now
for me to get involved in any of this
YouTube BS so I'm just not I don't know
who's saying what I'm not watching any
of these shows and I couldn't tell you
Dalbert Leal says hi David keep up the
work on the briefings Thank You Tyler
3000 says the UK is officially on
lockdown I just saw that and in fact in
fact tweeted about it the right decision
and we just went on a stay at home order
here in Massachusetts today
now basically we've already been on one
the only real change I'm identifying is
that all businesses that are
non-essential now are being directed to
closed
whereas before it was bars and
restaurants need to do takeout delivery
only no congregating in groups of more
than ten now it's getting very much more
real and very quickly
Jared Ken barrows says do you have any
info on kovat 19 reinfection yes I know
that there's a lot of rumors swirling
around about people can get it twice
I've spoken to multiple doctors about
this we have an interview 25 minutes
with some of the most common questions
about kovat 19 with the top infection
disease specialist at the University of
Toronto or Toronto or I can't really do
it the right way with the Canadian
accent but in any case isaac bogus
answered so many of your questions we're
publishing that in a few hours it
appears as though as with basically
viruses in general if you actually fight
it off you are immune for at least a
year up to potentially life if it
mutates significantly there's the
potential of reinfection in the future
if it's essentially a different virus by
the time it comes back but the reports
of reinfection appear to be people who
were not actually recovered or people
who had false negatives and then tested
positive and they were really positive
all along or people who did recover but
then had a false positive we are not
seeing actual evidence right now of
actual reinfection from people who truly
were recovered and that doesn't change
what anybody should be doing but it does
tell us that this is like a virus where
once you develop once you fight it off
you develop antibodies it would be great
to have an antibody test and I talked
about that with the doctor today in this
interview that that we're going to be
publishing for sure okay let me thank a
few other people Joshua Icefall is new
member number five today at join
pakman.com Jennifer Hall is new member
number six at join pakman.com Sean
Callahan is new member number seven at
join pakman.com and Camela or kamala
right
is new member number eight today at join
pakman.com while you guys are here I
hope that folks are basically just
staying at home and I know that for a
lot of people that means boredom so we
had this idea back before impeachment
started of doing a David Pakman show
chess tournament I'm a very amateur
chess player I've played against some
people in my audience
we have rescheduled that chess
tournament for this Wednesday night at
8:00 p.m. Eastern so you don't have to
be an experienced player it's open to
anybody we're going to be doing the
chess tournament on Lee chess org so if
you want get an account on Lee chess org
I'll be streaming my participation so
all of my games I will stream it'll just
be an hour tournament from 8:00 to 9:00
p.m. Eastern Wednesday night I would
love for you to participate
I'm very conservatively hoping we have
50 players which would be really cool
and anybody who wants to can play we
will be tweeting out and and obviously
on stream I will say what the link is
you can only create a tournament like an
hour before which is why I can't direct
people anywhere now but that'll be
Wednesday night at 8:00 p.m. Eastern
we're doing everything we can to give
people stuff to do rather than going out
and possibly exposing themselves or
others to the virus so a David Pakman
show chess tournament and oh I have let
me see if I can reach this as a gag gift
for my birthday because at the end of
the year producer Pat and I played one
game of chess and I won right now I am
david pakman show chess champion but the
winner on Wednesday will get their own
trophy and we will that that'll be the
prize we are giving away a trophy and
probably a bunch of stuff from the David
Pakman show store as well we have the
very popular data mail t-shirt that
people have been buying so we'll put
together like a package a sizable
stimulus package for for the winner of
the chess tournament on Wednesday so
anyway participate play it's something
to do we're all just trying to
responsibly as as they say responsibly
passed the time and it's going to be
it'll be three
minute games one-hour tournament maybe
an hour and a half or something like
that we'll see I see people already
telling me it's the wrong duration so I
apologize okay what else did we want to
talk about Oh Italy numbers okay
we always let's refresh
so just what we've been talking 400 new
cases have been diagnosed we always want
to be very careful about making any
optimistic statements but we have some
data from Italy that maybe maybe is
starting to turn around in the right
direction because what's going on in
Italy is tragic on March 21st there were
6500 new cases on March 22nd there were
5500 that's a decline of a thousand new
cases today so far 4800 new cases which
when it's added to the graph if that
goes final will be another decrease
Italy needs to do it okay by the way
look at this total scam troll ad right
here it's crazy so hopefully that is
starting to turn around now tragically
another 600 deaths in Italy today if you
look at the daily deaths that also would
be a decrease for two days in a row
Italy had almost 800 people died two
days ago 650 died yesterday if indeed
this number is final 601 that will be
three days of two days really during
which we saw a decrease in new cases in
Italy and a decrease in deaths in Italy
it's early we you know we just we don't
know yet but that's something meanwhile
the numbers in the US are horrible now
of course remember that the numbers in
the US we have a much larger population
than many of these countries it's
important to understand the concept of
per capita but the real concern in the
u.s. is this it's the speed with which
the cases are accelerating now of course
if you bring on new testing at a
disproportionately fast route what a
disgusting earwax add I'm sorry about
that let me scroll down I think it's
gonna be time I must sort of against
adblock
on principle because we depend on ad
revenue but these ads are getting
absolutely disgusting I'm gonna have to
do something about that look the
acceleration is is sick so you know we
we are we're in for the long haul here
in the United States active cases going
up and of course deaths also and deaths
are not related to testing deaths are
related to serious cases that are
leading to people dying and and
everything is increasing faster and
faster in the United States and that is
bad that is very very bad
we'll follow it day to day and again you
really need at least a few days to be
able to start making identified trends
so to speak let me say thanks to Britton
Mangum Britton Mangum is new member
number nine today at join pakman.com
very much appreciate everybody who has
picked up memberships and I want to say
thanks on twitch to Q Slim Thug P Q Slim
Thug P who is a a new twitch prime
subscriber we are just a few minutes
from the scheduled start that's all we
know they've been pretty late on on
these pretty consistently if you're just
joining us on YouTube please do me the
favor of hitting that like button and
also hit that subscribe button we
somehow have 5,000 viewers and only 600
likes that that makes me has a sad and
we don't we certainly don't want that
Daniel Krieger says Senate is
disgraceful right now yep
again I today on the program and these I
don't I'm not gonna redo all this stuff
because we're publishing clips
throughout the day on it but I did a
list of what should have been done
already and ahead of time there should
have been a negotiation and a framework
for what are we going to provide now
they're just arguing Democrats aren't
going forward because they say it's
essentially a Republican slush fund for
Steve minutia
to administer which it is it's an
absolute disgusting mess and it's just
people who are who are suffering as a
result Charlie says do you think foul
she will attend today I hope so I hope
so we need we need some logic and reason
at these briefings
a right says do you think we enter the
Great Depression number two I don't know
anybody pretending to know is is merely
guessing Christy J says is it mental
illness or is it ego which makes Trump
uncontrollable what are your thoughts I
don't know but he is out of control and
tomorrow I'm already planning a segment
on not Trump's lies so far as president
because that's like 16,000 not Trump's
lies on the virus so far because that's
in the hundreds it will be just Trump's
lies about coronavirus over the last 48
hours and that alone needs so much
unpacking to to sort of fight the spread
of disinformation quirky quips says oh
sorry Oh looks like we're going live
soon all right look we are one step
closer to going live that's good let me
see here I missed work equip says a lady
said she doesn't have the patience to
wash for 20 seconds new patient wishes
she washed to I will survive for 20
seconds yeah nobody has the time to wash
your hands 20 seconds until you get the
virus tika says any guess on how many
tremendous is we here today thanks for
the contest content so yesterday I asked
people to keep track of how many times
Trump used the word tremendous and a
couple people emailed me that he used it
21 times during yesterday's briefing you
know I guess we can let's let's put the
over-under at 21 assuming that that was
yesterday's count and see whether Trump
does does more or less of that today
Steve Spade you nachus says what's the
deal with Pelosi and her stalling the
GOP stimulus bill well importantly this
is a double-edged sword we don't want to
stall the bill but the bill is being set
up as a slush fund for Steve minuchin to
hand out cash to companies that Trump
likes that's not going to help the
average person and so it's a very
disgusting situation because the
American people lose and the economy
loses the stock market today was
actually doing ok if we go back and look
at
Dow intraday if you look at the Dow
intraday there was actually a period
during which it was doing okay and then
it ended up falling off a cliff and it
was just an absolute in total mess let
me see if I can get a better easier to
read chart yeah and actually this that's
weird because - 532 did this doesn't
make it seem like there was a period
during which it was up but I vividly
remember that there was maybe this
doesn't make it clear what the open what
the previous closed was rather it just
shows us where were the open was but
every day that this is delayed is a bad
day for small business it's a bad day
for the average American you get closer
to starting to see the mortgage industry
implode people not being able to pay
mortgages and all of this has follow-on
effects that are extraordinarily
problematic they've got to get it done
gotta get it done maybe tomorrow maybe
now Jackson says that person just lied
about what destiny said he didn't say
all Bernie supporters are shills are
idiots he complained specifically about
the toxic online community he does hate
Kyle but that's reasonable yeah again
this is I'm not even reacting to this
stuff because I don't even know if
people are telling me what's going on
and it just it doesn't matter our rich
rope ethics says why the eff is it
snowing now it is snowing here in Boston
but it is winter oh no it's it's spring
actually no that's not even true is it
spring yeah it's spring I don't know not
a meteorologist myself
Kevin Sellars says thanks Dave for your
stream dumb Donald can never be trusted
Alex D says can anyone stop the
pharmaceutical price gouging this drugs
from price gouging this drugs I don't
know it's it's sick what's going on Jeff
the god of biscuit says Rand Paul not
quarantine is no worse than someone
who's knowingly exposed to HIV still
having unprotected sex while waiting
test results yeah the word is that Rand
Paul between having the test and getting
a positive result went to the Senate gym
or something like that Walter says do
you think the 15-day plan was
communicated properly to
people know people seem to have no idea
when it even started right it wasn't
strong enough Trump's acting like we're
in the middle of a deep hunkering down
after which we might be able to all come
out half the country's not doing a damn
thing yet when half the country hasn't
even started the isolation it's going to
be very difficult to imagine that it
will it will succeed and we will see
what Trump has planned for for a week
from now
okay yes people are asking am i still
giving away free stuff every five
members we give away an item from the
online store to one of those five folks
so for from new members one to five
today at join pakman.com one of those
five people will get an email after the
stream saying you won the free item four
member six through ten if and when we
get to ten another four every five
memberships we're giving away a free
item and by far the most popular item
these days is the data mail t-shirt and
the designer of the shirt also is going
to come up with a different graph color
for the red shirt so that the contrast
will be better we haven't sold any red
shirts I think you can tell why the just
it didn't quite work on that one the
most popular color heather gray followed
by a banana cream love banana cream and
then the white shirt I ordered a white
one I'm still waiting on delivery I'll
probably start wearing it during the
streams once once it comes in but yes we
will keep giving away free stuff as as
people sign up BC says 67 days for
100,000 cases 11 for the second hundred
thousand cases four for the third
hundred thousand cases that is that is
called viral growth that is that is what
it is
Dinkins says hi David what's your take
on how governors are handling responding
to the virus specifically Cuomo and
Pritzker I don't know that much about
pritzker Cuomo seems to be generally
handling it well I've not been able to
watch everybody's briefings but I think
that
if this is going to be solved if this is
going to be solved sooner than later
it's heavily going to depend on
governor's because what we're getting
from Trump is trash you could put it
right in the garbage can Alex Jones says
destiny called you an idiot communists
what are your thoughts again you know I
have no reason to believe that that's
what Stephen said and he knows I'm not a
communist it would be very surprising to
me if he said that but once again I am
NOT going to comment on things I haven't
seen or don't watch awesome gaming says
what do you think about us unemployment
rate may skyrocket to 30% you know I
heard 20% as a worse case I don't know
we're gonna have to deal with those
numbers and in fact we are going to get
unemployment numbers 7 8 9 10 and 11 12
we're 12 days from getting March
unemployment numbers we'll get those on
April 3rd and then we will we will have
more information let me say thanks to
Neptune 99 for gifting a subscription on
Twitch also want to say thanks to sim
Gitchell or gazelle for subscribing with
twitch prime really appreciate that we
are live on Twitch YouTube Twitter
Twitter and Facebook and I announced
earlier Wednesday night at 8:00 p.m.
Eastern Time will be the David Pakman
show chess tournament Onley chess org
everybody's welcome regardless of skill
level it's a free website grab a gret
can just sign up on the site li chess
org and then I'll be streaming and we're
this is a community event I hope a lot
of you will participate I have this goal
of 50 people participating because I
don't know how many people in my
audience play chess but maybe people
more people will it is Wednesday night
this Wednesday March 25 8 p.m. Eastern
Time 8 p.m. Eastern Time everybody's
welcome to play Oscar edge says please
mention the Swedish situation we
actively chose as the only country not
to test widely as a strategy only I see
you we won't even know if we've had it I
honestly I
the first I'm hearing of that I can't
really comment much about it
Rick Hernandez says what is your chess
rating I'm in the 1300 range for slower
games and you know successively lower
for faster and faster games let's see
here Jay Jay HWH says six of my
relatives are infected one died one is
in hospital rest quarantined at least
none of my immediate family members
because of caution yeah I remember
yesterday you mentioning that and that
is that's horrible I my condolences it's
absolutely horrible
we're very quickly going from we've all
heard of someone we know having it too
we all now may know people who are in
serious condition and hospitalized a
very close friend of my family's lives
in Bergamo which is like the epicenter
of this in northern Italy and he's in
the hospital recovering and hopefully
hopefully we'll be able to leave the
hospital in the next week remember if
you're just joining on YouTube please
hit that like button and also the
subscribe button both are very very much
appreciated okay I think I just closed
out I was trying to look at who just
signed up for membership so I can thank
people and it didn't work and now I'm
pulling it back up there we go okay
apologies about that and there we go now
I lost my super chats let me pull those
back up everything going wrong here all
of a sudden here we go okay let me say
thanks to Angela Lyon who is new member
number 10 at join pakman.com chad
williams is new member number 11 today
at join pakman.com and oh that's it
all right I'm caught up very nice okay
Adam Waddington says oh no I skipped
sorry if John Sebastian Pinera says hey
David hope you're doing well two
questions do you follow any major league
soccer
I don't controversial question Diego
Maradona or Leo Messi you know
I am much more familiar with Messi and
you know what's happened to Maradona has
been tragic the the drug use and
everything else so basically I'm opting
out I'm opting out of that question but
I'm much more familiar with with Leo
Messi's game as I followed it much more
closely
Adam Waddington says the best was when
he said tremendous package yes Steve
Spano Dhaka says thanks I didn't
understand
no problem Steve glad to be here a rich
Roper thak says did Snowden choose
Moscow cuz it's a den of snow no idea
bad at gaming has grabbed the YouTube
subscription Steve Spano Dhaka says it's
pronounced span a Dacus by the way
okay apologies after saying it wrong
three times Steve Spano Dacus I should
remember that love inspired 7 says I
have a slightly better drinking game
idea take 2 shots every time Trump opens
and closes his hands while talking yes
sometimes when trump's explaining things
it's almost like he's drawing like a
silhouette of a woman silly
silhouette silhouette daniel block has
grabbed a membership adam Waddington
says I can't believe Biden beat Bernie
when he has been silent on kovat while
Bernie does the right thing in live
streams regularly what a waste yeah
today I retweeted a clip of Joe Biden
today having a teleprompter malfunction
it was not good he thought the number of
responders dealing with the crush these
crushing cases and and in addition to
that in addition to that we have to make
sure that we we are in a position that
we are well let me let me go the second
thing I've spoken up in it the president
must use ok
so that's not good also it looked like
it was a green screen of his living room
with a podium in front like it just it
was bad it was really really bad so you
know we're gonna have to keep a very
very close eye on that and see kind of
what what continues what continues to
happen
thanks to Ashlee ray for getting a SOI
boy level membership on YouTube
vibrantly Brantley says you're my
favorite David that lives in your area
oh okay that seems less strong Emmett
says have you been watching Cuomo's
press briefings and what do you think of
them I've been watching a little bit I
think that they're by and large very
good and much more informative than what
we've seen from Donald Trump obviously
Mort Jadis says do you think Republicans
are more prone to infection and death
from the virus couldn't tell you
couldn't tell you Paul Donnelly has sent
a super chapped Fanny key ii says please
check out the Cova act now site yeah
that's a good website I'll pull it up a
covert act now the interesting thing
about kovat act now hold on a second
kovat act now.org covert act now does
something interesting which is it will
show you on the basis of where you live
so like if I pick Massachusetts it'll
say if you do nothing this is the
trajectory if you do three months of
social distancing and this would be the
trajectory if you do three months of
shelter in place this would be the
trajectory so the idea here would be
like if Massachusetts shelters in place
by July 1st we will have had only 3,300
hospitalizations which is below this
black line which is the capacity the
expected beds available and you can do
this for your state it also lists a
point of no return for intervention to
prevent hospital overload we're in that
window right now how accurate this is I
don't know but quite frankly if it just
scares people into doing the right thing
it's a good thing and we should we
should be paying attention Massachusetts
of course as I mentioned earlier we are
now in a stay at home order at this
point okay Alex D says any truth that
China has a vaccine no evidence of that
heard about it says is Eric Rosen
joining to you should ask him tonight I
would love it if Erica joined my chess
tournament I think he would probably win
farmer Kip says what is the time
format for the chess tourney I'm
thinking three plus two what I'm willing
to be convinced one way or the other
three plus two seems like it would be a
good format for a tournament that will
be 60 to 90 minutes long so that it's
not like crazy crazy long but people can
still get a fair number of games in
that's my thought as of right now 3 2 or
5 - yeah I think 5 you know with 5 -
games can be 15 minutes long and you
know I don't know I don't know about
that
Shannon Bennett says what did you make
of Biden's cringy c9 response yeah we
just looked at a clip of that Ralph
Williams has grabbed a YouTube
membership wreck soul says do you play
Final Fantasy games like Asuna no I
don't Lake Luke Thuan says do you feel
governor Baker is doing enough to slow
the spread should he be ordering more
businesses to close and issuing a real
shelter in place well today Charlie
Baker issued a all non-essential
businesses should close now if you're
saying that more there should be fewer
types of businesses listed is
non-essential that's a different sort of
question but I think he's doing a pretty
good job I think he's doing a pretty
good job let me say thank you to Robin
and Smith whose new member number 12
today at join pakman.com Ellen clash qey
SPO SPO is new member number 13 at join
pakman.com and i also want to say thank
you to oh no that's it okay
my caught up there I am caught up
appreciate that very much
okay we are 17 minutes past the
scheduled start time for today's press
conference as usual they tend to start
very very late we do have live video and
people have been slowly filing into the
room so hopefully it will start soon
remember if you're watching currently on
Twitter make sure you're following me if
you're watching on Facebook make sure to
give us a like if you're watching on
twitch of course make sure you're
following me we are approaching 30 2004
Twitch and to the 6500 folks beautiful
kind folks watching on you
tube remember to like and subscribe and
if you're on android you have to close
the live chat box in order to like and
subscribe
Austin Aggie man says if we view
everything Trump does as authoritarian
quarantine nationalizing industry but
complain he isn't doing enough what's
the middle ground well the only thing
I've said that Trump oh we've got audio
coming from somewhere okay looks like we
have some some audio there from a tech
person the only thing that I believe the
Trump administration is trying to do
that's authoritarian is suspending
habeas corpus by it by allowing people
to be held indefinitely without a trial
that they've not done that they're
trying to get that done
national quarantine would not be
authoritarian enforcing the defense
production act would not be
authoritarian so 5uu you should ask
someone who's been saying those things I
certainly have not silent D says hello
David for everyone that recovers can't
they catch it again if they come in
contact with someone who has it dealt
with that earlier no evidence of that
the supposedly infection when you fight
off a virus you are immune how long
depends on how quickly the virus mutates
and other factors it is believed people
who recover are immune for any somewhere
between one year and the rest of their
lives and the supposed reinfection x'
appear to have been either people who
tested positive because they actually
never recovered and maybe had a false
negative at some point or false
positives for people who did actually
recover John Howell says backcap gammon
is better for smocking
I don't play backgammon so that's why
that's why we're doing a chess
tournament maverick says thoughts on two
trillion-dollar coronavirus bill again
because we don't know what's going to be
passed instead of commenting every day
on something that may not even become a
reality I'm going to wait until they
pass something but before I comment
otherwise we're you know I'd be
consuming so much time on
that not aren't even getting past austin
clark says high school teacher in rural
South Utah here
our plan is to resume school week next
week local Department of Health Director
still thinks it's the same as the flu
Shane yeah the these parts of the
country are truly going to be screwed if
that's if that's what they do
waffles Durazo forger offals you weren't
a reason to not name my four-year-old
David not sure I understand that one
government says I do not trust that
China is handling the virus well
considering the CCP are notorious liars
I understand that but based on the w-h-o
folks that are in China they claim that
China really is now doing a good job of
course after you know weeks of
authoritarian lockdowns let me say thank
you on twitch to Dan of Earth who's now
been subscribed 5 months I appreciate
that
also want to say thanks to NASA var who
has subscribed with prime on twitch
really appreciate that glad that folks
are watching on twitch as we are
hopefully just a few minutes from the
start today although it's still looking
pretty low energy in the room so it's
anyone's guess how close we are at this
point at AZ share says just me finding
out about Andrew Gilliam scandal I heard
about the Andrew Gilliam scandal a
couple of days ago or maybe five days
ago I don't know Andrew Gilliam yeah I
guess caught with drugs in a hotel room
and it was it was pretty ugly pretty
ugly counterpart says this week it'll
come out if Switzerland starts to
recover or becomes Italy 2.0 wish us
luck and keep up the good work
yeah so let's look at Switzerland
Switzerland has been having a ton of
cases here it is Switzerland as you can
see in total cases for a relatively
small country has many many cases the
death rate has been low thus far and the
question is is that going to increase or
not and we are we are going to figure
that out pretty soon as you can see
a bunch of countries in Switzerland have
hit a little bit of I'm sorry a bunch of
countries in Europe have hit a bit of an
inflection point a few days ago we have
to see if it's temporary or if this may
be the start of going in the right
direction we just don't know yet
Daniel Rivera says next time do a bullet
chess tournament alright we'll see this
is not an alias says David how long
would you speculate we have until Trump
rage fires doctor foul Qi you know I
heard a rumor that that might have been
happening today so let me just take a
look let me do a search for Trump ouchy
on Google News not seeing that yet yeah
I don't know
ouchy ouchy may be gone sooner than
later the way things have been going
Jacob Ratner says take on California
saying weed shops are essential I you
know I want to leave that to the experts
I don't know I don't know
super chat says will Ken Ham open Ark
Park in Kentucky for hospital beds would
not count on it
Lonny Kratz has grabbed a youtube
subscription Steve Spano Dacus says
Trump refuses to lock down the entire
country because he wants to shift blame
on governor's that may be part of it he
also just doesn't want to take the
economic hit which he end up may end up
taking anyway if this continues to get
worse Joe pull Cheney says via YouTube
super chat lots of great educational
material and concerts on the youtubes
thanks Pakman yeah I've been watching
philosophy courses by Shelly Kagan
excellent excellent philosophy professor
highly recommend it if you guys are
looking looking for stuff to watch or e
oppose says possible to get the virus
twice two strains I've already answered
that twice so I'm not not going to do it
again our buckle says Trump's hand
movements resemble someone playing an
invisible bandoneon pardon me Rollo and
Piazzolla a Troilo and Patty oh yes oh
yeah alright vitruvian man says I fed is
spend infinite money to buy stock assets
why do corporations need a bailout the
it's just not enough would be the
argument they need to do all of the
above Devin says why can't we just shoot
the corona in the legs lor a.m. epsom
says hi David I've been boating blue no
matter who for four decades hostage
voting has not really worked out well
for me
what is your long game extensive clip
about that on my youtube channel that I
uploaded recently as the room starts to
fill up here we I will remind you we are
at 13 of 25 new members the best way to
support these streams and we've been
doing them everyday we haven't missed a
day for a while at this point is to grab
a membership at join pakman.com it's
quick it's easy it feels good and most
importantly you can save 66 percent with
that wacky coupon code 2020 now YouTube
and other online ad revenue is down
about 30% because of the coronavirus
situation so we're streaming daily
hoping to replace some of that revenue
so that nobody has to take a cut in ours
or any of that no layoffs
none of that stuff we're doing streams
daily in order to try to supplement
supplement as the kids these days like
to say any ghosts says since we no
official government kovat case numbers
are often massaged would it be possible
for your team to track and disseminate
more useful metrics I watched a video on
a Preppers Channel and he tracks cases
of undiagnosed pneumonia occupied ICU
beds versus capacity and optics in
pretty crime I assume you mean petty
crime which he mentioned was increasing
due to social anxiety you don't even
need to do that there are actually a lot
of people on YouTube who are doing
pretty good estimates of how the
official case number relates to the real
case number so so that's already being
done and but by people far better at
math than I am let me let me leave it at
that
Amanda Panda says don't fall for the
Sweden thing it's a right-wing lie to
make Social Democrats look bad Sweden is
one of the countries doing the most
tests
they are simply doing it more targeted
well let's see world ah meter Co vid
testing numbers let's see what the
official numbers are for how much
testing has been done let's take a look
here Sweden Sweden is not even on the
list okay well I guess I have no idea
yeah we don't have any information about
official numbers about Swedish testing
so I don't know I'm not in Sweden we've
heard two very different perspectives so
far asserted I don't know what's going
on with testing in Sweden Stein our
Husby says is the corona pandemic a
risky topic for Biden to approach right
now or is inaction a worse choice I
think inaction is worse but if you look
at how today's briefing went then you
know who knows let me see here looks
like I've been logged out of my own list
of who is signing up for memberships
which is weird
okay I'm back in very good let me say
thank you to Craig Metzger Craig Metzger
is new member number 14 Thank You Craig
at join pakman.com this press briefing
was scheduled for 5:30 p.m. Eastern time
that was 27 minutes ago they'd start
their starting later and later everyday
and we don't know why but they are
and hopefully soon they will get going
let me also say thanks to Shemer of
orsha Maariv for subscribing for five
months on Twitch with the message tee
and brief tee and brief alright thank
you Matt bell says elements of metal is
a sensible elemental message couldn't
agree more
couldn't agree more Beezus says when
countries are not genetically diverse
like Switzerland they risk having huge
epidemics this is an argument for
immigration generic diver genetic
diversity that's interesting I've not
heard that before but it is very
interesting wilbur johnson says new
mexico Govan
our orders stay at home order it's the
right decision
it hurts listen when I saw today that
Charlie Baker here in Massachusetts said
two weeks of stay at home I don't like
it but we've got to do it we've got to
do it today if you're a member by the
way we do an extra show every day for
our paid members and today producer Pat
joined us from his personal gym and
recreation room you will see on today's
bonus show if you remember and you and
you check it out you will see that Pat
has both the ping-pong table and a
punching bag in the room where he is now
producing the show and it's pretty
compelling stuff I'm not gonna lie let
me say thanks to Nick Verna who is new
member number 15 today at join
pakman.com Nick yes yes I also want to
say thanks to Sean McDonough who is new
member number 16 today Thank You Sean
Tushar Mohammed is new member number 17
today and Joseph Rosh is new member
number 18 at join pakman.com thanks very
much and remember it's free to support
these streams if you're watching on
youtube just hit that like button and
hit that subscribe button you know it's
crazy
thirty-nine thousand different people
have entered the stream today and only
2300 opted to hit like isn't that sad
maybe maybe it's just me maybe it's not
a big deal to others okay I'm kidding by
the way Brian Wagner says what's the
breaking point for Trump I think we're
close when when reporters asked softball
questions and he attacks them you know
you're getting close to Trump's breaking
point Chris Kiefel says foutch E is
great he will be further muzzled soon
you're probably right
William C says man and woman is ill
after taking chloroquine yeah this is
why it's so irresponsible for Donald
Trump to tweet this is a game changer
but this is the thing this is this is
what's going on and this is what's going
to gonna cure everybody you get people
who start prick
during these medications and I actually
got a report today from a doctor in San
Diego I believe it was saying multiple
people are having heart issues because
of taking chloroquine with zero Meissen
so you've got to study this stuff
carefully this is why it's dangerous
that Donald Trump says this is the game
changer I feel so good about it I'm a
smart guy you start hearing these
absolutely horrible horrible stories
this is not an alias says David could
you give a shout-out to my
seven-year-old daughter Lucy please
thanks you're the best absolutely Lucy I
hope you're staying safe I hope your
your parent don't know if this is your
dad or your mom is also not getting too
much on your nerves during the
quarantine and the isolation but yes
shout out to Lucy dan samoflange says
thoughts on gun shops being essential
businesses to stay open as people are
unemployed crime could go up I had not
heard that gun shops are considered
essential businesses and I wonder if
that state-by-state I don't know and if
in Massachusetts a gun shop would be
considered an essential business Lian
I'm sorry Raghu Auriga says do you think
trumpets will finally realize now that
he is a con man or is he still the
president that going to be the best
president ever for them no Trump's
approval rating has gone up during the
coronavirus crisis it's inconceivable
inconceivable Lian says how much power
should people with no expertise have in
decision-making I ideally not that not
that much greetings from Germany we're
epidemiologists dominate the public
discourse yeah actually let's look at
the Germany numbers briefly because
Germany let's see here Germany is
incredibly maintaining an extremely low
death rate extremely low death rate now
there's a couple factors here let me
pull up my calculator the official death
rate right now in Germany again based on
official cases is 0.4 percent that's
fantastic but a couple things we're not
really calculating the death rate
correctly because only when someone
what only when a case has resolved can
you say it's over and so only four
hundred and fifty three of the twenty
nine thousand cases have recovered
Germany is a question and there's an
interesting article that I tweeted out
about it a few days ago the article
wasn't Spanish but you can run it
through through Google Translate and
it'll be pretty good Germany is doing
very very well
in terms of the death rate and Germany
has also now had two days in a row with
significantly lower cases hitting a max
of forty five hundred now down to twenty
five hundred two days in a row and let
me see where they're at today German oh
okay
not today not a good day forty one
hundred new cases in Germany today yes
so the German low death rate phenomenon
has been written about it pretty
extensively and we'll see where it goes
obviously we hope that they're able to
keep the death rate as low as it has
been brains do says down with Trump al
Pueblo UNIDO Hamas said oh and see
though yes a united community will never
be defeated is the message from brain
still coming to us in Spanish today
James Justice says what kind of drum kit
you got so I have a Mapex acoustic kit
and then I have a roland electric drum
set right now only the e kit is set up
our our Cham says is relieving 30,000
and student student debt really a
realistic thing that could happen with
this relief package
I'm skeptical but cautiously optimistic
right I mean that would be great but I
remain skeptical on if and until it
happens let me say thank you to Barbara
Allen Barbara you are new member number
nineteen today at join pakman.com
Marilyn Cooper you are new member number
twenty at join pakman.com thank you so
much
KC Mathieu is new member number 21 today
at join pakman.com let me say thank you
to Susanne Sheets who is new member
number 22 today at join pakman.com
Philip Raley is new member number 23 at
join pakman.com Daniel poser you poser
know you're a real member new member
number 24 today I joined pakman.com also
want to say thanks to Thomas Glen stripe
who is new member number 25 so let's go
for 50 why don't we do it I also want to
say thanks to Holden spittle era whose
new member number 26 today and Nicholas
Bauer is new member number 27 thanks so
much I really appreciate that I also
want to say thanks to Jonathan Espen all
whose new member number 28 thank you so
much I the the membership support has
been crucial and you know we really are
so lucky we were talking today I was
talking with our team all decentralized
everybody's working from home everybody
relaxed everybody's working from home
how we all now know people who straight
like their business they're the places
where they work have just closed okay so
we thankfully are only dealing with some
people cancelling memberships because
they are tightening the belt
understandably this is not you know that
this is not food rent transportation and
YouTube revenue for ads is down about
30% so with that you know we I can we
can float that and the people who have
been signing up at joined pakman.com
during the streams are what is what is
balancing that out which we really
really very much appreciate okay
kyle ji has grabbed the youtube syboy
subscription Rhonda boy says aerosol
masking effect it's about to get warm
aerosol masking effect it's about to get
warm I don't know if you're saying this
is going to get better when it gets warm
or worse and there are theories in both
degrees black wave asks is there curfew
for New York City in California I don't
know the answer to that you'd have to
check in your state thanks to Frank ow
xander for grabbing a soy boy level
youtube membership Kyle says have you
talked about Sandra's proposal in the
Senate no so lists here's the thing
there's so much news each day everybody
has a proposal Senate candidate Joe
Kennedy congressman has a proposal
Bernie as a proposal ROH Khanna has a
proposal
Trump has one McConnell hunt you know
all these different things because we
have so much to cover and it could be a
long time until the proposal is done we
just have made the decision we're not
going to talk to specifically on the
show about specific proposals because we
could just spend every day talking about
the latest proposal I've laid out what
needs to happen individual support small
business support we need to look at rent
deferrals for businesses and on and on
and on so so we're at this point I'm
waiting to see what they actually pass
that Chavez says this will be worse than
the Great Depression prepare Trinity
Valley North Central has grabbed the You
Tube membership Alex Jones says can you
imagine being friends I'm not even gonna
read this stuff I I know Alex you're
really keyed up on having me just read
negative things about William bars here
oh boy that can't be good I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna just read things about
destiny which then you you probably are
gonna get him to react to it's not that
we're not doing that Stephen desk
Stephen Kenneth is a friend of mine and
I don't even you know I don't keep I
don't know Kyle Cole in skis every
political position he and I were texting
yesterday you know I talked to Kenneth
and everybody I don't know all their
politics I don't really watch political
shows and that's it okay Robert
Archer says I think that briefings are
delayed every day because Trump is
hoping to gather more viewers since he
cares so much about ratings yeah you
know the language Trump uses it's crazy
I mentioned yesterday Trump often talks
about things he believes will be popular
with coronavirus customers it's it's
incredible language it's incredible
language notice by the way that Anthony
foutch II is not on the stage once again
dr. Burks is and she sometimes will
sense but foul she again missing and
it's pretty clear at this point in my
mind particularly after the article that
that went live today about foul she's
saying you know Trump lies all the time
but when we're gonna do fight them every
time yell every time we may not see foul
Chi at these anymore we don't know okay
Tracy Lin has grabbed a youtube
membership and oh boy
Steve span a day kiss says I feel like
there are more coronavirus deaths here
in the US but they aren't counted
towards the numbers because of the lack
of early testing yeah so one there's one
of you that we can't trust the case
numbers but we can trust the death
numbers there's another view that we
can't trust the death numbers because
not everybody's getting tested and some
people may just die of pneumonia we
don't know if it was cove at 19 they
weren't tested and it may not count as
as as a death I don't know at this point
I don't know who we can trust and who we
can't trust let me say thank you to a
few other folks
Raymond behringer is new member number
29 today at join pakman.com Raymond yes
yes Geoffrey Goldwater is new member
number 30 today at join pakman.com
felicia Breeland hi Felicia
is new member number 31 appreciate that
elaine petty is new member number 32
today Dianne Noland oh boy that is a lot
of consonants Dianne I'm gonna do the
best I can with this Dianne Noland Jack
oh boy Jack I apologize is new member
number 33 today Troy Caldwell is new
member number 34 and Samuel Menard is
number 35 here is Trump let's see what
we got
well thank you very much and I see we
have fewer people because of the virus
problem and we appreciate you being here
and this is getting to be more and more
social distancing and that's fine so it
should be and it's too bad we extend our
best wishes to the person affected and
we feel sure that he or she will be
better very soon and thank you for being
here America continues this trumpet did
someone in the press corps now get it
and now people are spacing out to turn
the tide in the battle against the virus
I want Americans to know that we will
get through this on opening with Chinese
virus every time didn't do it there
that's interesting and it will end soon
normal life will return and our economy
will rebound very very strongly but
right now in the midst of this great
national trial Americans must remain
united in purpose and focused on victory
to every single American please know
that the sacrifice you're making at this
time is saving lives many many lives
it's very important that we totally
protect our Asian American community in
the United States and all around the
world change of tune they're amazing
people and the spreading of the virus is
not their fault in any way shape or form
Wow they're working closely with us to
get rid of it we will prevail together
it's very important from the beginning
we have been working closely with our
nation's best scientists and medical
professionals and we will continue to do
so until we have defeated the virus our
public health experts who are terrific
are studying the variation and the
disease across the country and we will
be using data to recommend new protocols
to allow local economies to cautiously
resume their activity at the appropriate
time we also have a large team working
on what the next steps will be once the
medical community gives a region the
okay
meaning the okay to get going to get
back let's go to work
our country wasn't built to be shut down
this is not a country that was built for
this it was not built to be shut down my
administration continues to work with
Democrats and Republicans to reach an
agreement on an urgent relief bill for
the millions of American workers and
small businesses and large businesses
that were badly affected by the medical
difficulty that we've had a medical
difficulty if you had a viable business
in January we are committed to ensuring
the same is true in the coming weeks in
fact we want to make it even better than
it was before we're doing things to help
in that regard America will again and
soon be open for business
very soon a lot sooner than three or
four months if somebody was suggesting
lot sooner we cannot let the Cure be
worse than the problem itself we're not
gonna let the Cure be worse than the
problem at the end of the 15 day period
we'll make a decision as to which way we
want to go where we want to go the
timing and essentially we're referring
to the timing of the opening essentially
the opening of our country because we
have it pretty well shut down in order
to get rid of this invisible enemy two
weeks ago we moved at record speed to
pass paid sick leave and paid Family
Medical Leave and approve eight billion
dollars including money for the
development of treatments and vaccines
and we're doing tremendous work in both
on both fronts and the vaccines are
coming along very quickly now Congress
must demonstrate the same bipartisanship
again and joined together to pass the
Senate bill is written and avoid playing
any more partisan games they have to get
together and just stop with the partisan
politics and I think that's happening I
got a call a little while ago I guess
they're getting closer it should go
quickly
must go quickly it's not really a choice
to have a choice to have to make a deal
there should not be a time for political
agendas but rather one for focusing
solely and squarely on the needs of the
American people we are going to save
American workers and we're going to save
them quickly and we're going to save our
great American companies both small and
large this was a medical problem we are
not going to let it turn into a
long-lasting financial problem started
out as a purely medical problem and it's
not going to go beyond that we're just
not going to allow that to happen our
country was at its strongest financial
point we've never had an economy like we
had just a few weeks ago and then it got
hit with something that nobody could
have ever thought possible and we are
fixing it we're fixing it quickly and I
want to just thank the American people
for what they've been through and what
they're doing not inspiring a new will
be stronger than ever before and we
fully anticipate that and it won't be
that long let me provide you with an
update on critical supplies FEMA is
distributing eight million n95
respirator masks and thirteen point
three million surgical masks of course
the country right now focusing on the
areas with the greatest need we've
shipped 73 pallets of personal
protective equipment to new york city
and 36 pallets to the state of
washington in the past 96 hours FEMA has
also received donations of approximately
6.5 million masks we're having millions
and millions of masks made as we speak
another personal protective equipment
which we will be distributing to medical
hotspots were focused on some of the hot
spots across the nation we're seeing an
outpouring of creativity and innovative
ideas widely shared between the federal
health leaders governors and mayors the
scientific community and members of the
private sector
really working together everybody's
working together I'm pleased to report
that clinical trials in New York will
begin existing for existing drugs that
may prove effective against the virus at
my direction the federal government is
working to help obtain large quantities
of chloroquine and you can look from any
standpoint tomorrow in New York we think
tomorrow pretty early the
hydroxychloroquine and the z-pak i think
is a combination probably is looking
very very good and unclear distributed
we have 10,000 units going and it'll be
distributed tomorrow it'll be available
and is now they already have it they're
going to distribute it tomorrow morning
to a lot of people in New York City and
New York well studying it very closely
watching it very closely you probably
saw a couple of articles today came out
where a gentleman they thought he was
not gonna make it he said goodbye to his
family they had given him the drug just
a little while before but he thought it
was over his family thought he was going
to die and yeah the problem is that
there's also people having heart issues
from from trying this medication you got
to be careful he's in good shape then
he's very happy for this particular drug
that we got approved in record-setting
time has never been anything even close
to it and I want to thank the FDA which
has been incredible and dr. hon Steven
Hahn had a respected man but they're
doing everything possible to increase
production and available supply of these
drugs not only this drug but also others
that are coming Renda severe is coming
from Regeneron a couple of others are
also under study but the one that I'm
very excited about right now is the one
we just mention again this excited stuff
a real chance I mean again we don't know
but there's a real chance that it could
have a tremendous impact it would be a
gift from God if that worked oh it would
be a big game-changer game today sir
again distribution starts tomorrow
morning early in New York and I think a
lot of people are going to be hopefully
they're gonna be very happy with the
result that we're all gonna be watching
closely it's something we have to try
it's been very very successful on
malaria very very successful and
countries with malaria have had a
interesting thing happened they take
this particular drug it's a very
powerful drug and there is very little
semblance of the virus in those
countries and there are those that say
because this drug is very prevalent
because of the malaria so we'll see that
I've not heard once I'm also announcing
that we're postponing the deadline for
compliance with Real ID requirements at
a time when we're asking Americans to
maintain social distancing we do want to
require people to go with their local
DMV you don't we will be announcing the
new deadline very soon it's going to be
announced in a very short moment
overnight we successfully brought home
one hundred and three American citizens
after they had been stranded for ten
days in Brazil following a cruise we
want to thank the Brazilian government
and their great president
most of those returned were senior
citizens my administration and
cooperation with Governor Greg Abbott of
Texas and the private sector coordinated
their safe return to the United States
so thank you to Governor Abbott terrific
governor terrific man earlier today I
signed an executive order invoking
presidential authority under Section 45
12 of the defense production Act to
prohibit the hoarding of vital medical
equipment and supplies such as hand
sanitizers face masks and
personal protective equipment we have a
lot of face mess a lot of equipment is
coming in and it's against some people
hoarding and Attorney General bar is
going to be speaking about that in a
second we want to prevent price gouging
and a critical health and medical
resources are going to be protected in
every form under this directive the
Secretary of Health and Human Services
is authorized to designate essential
health and medical supplies as scarce so
it'll designate certain supplies and
medical elements as scarce and that
means it will be a crime to stockpile
these items and excessive quantities
which is happening to a relatively small
degree we think but nevertheless it's
happened and we can't let it happen and
we can't let them resell them at
excessive prices which some people are
doing very simply will not allow anyone
to exploit the suffering of American
citizens for their own profit so we're
gonna be watching that with our great
Attorney General very closely the
Department of Justice will be
aggressively prosecuting fraudulent
schemes related to the pandemic
yesterday federal prosecutors took
action in their first case shutting down
a website selling a totally fake vaccine
if you can believe that one how about
Alex Jones is silver coronavirus
toothpaste exploited thankfully all
throughout the country we're witnessing
extraordinary acts of compassion
benevolence and unity construction
companies are donating masks by the
hundreds of thousands manufacturing
workers are transforming their assembly
lines citizens are volunteering to
deliver food and medicine to the elderly
we're truly seeing America at its best
we're really seeing things that people
never thought even could happen
everything's great frankly we never
thought this could happen but the way
most Americans are are working toward
getting it solved and and just doing
what they have to do to make this go
away has been a crowd
it's been incredible I want to take a
moment to thank the everyday heroes who
are making our vast your effort against
the virus possible and thank you to the
healthcare workers and the first
responders these are very brave people
thanks also to the hard-working men and
women of Federal Express UPS the United
States Postal Service and the truckers
who are maintaining our supply chains
and supply lines we thank you very much
great job we also want to give our
regards and thanks to everyone at our
grocery stores working the night shift
so that shelves can be restocked and the
restaurant workers and delivery drivers
keeping our families fed so many of
these restaurants it's incredible
they're doing service where people come
and they pick it up delivery I mean it's
been incredible yeah totally different
business there than they were in other
than they cook food other than that it's
like a totally different business most
of all I want to thank the American
people for rising to the challenge and
showing incredible courage determination
patience grace and grit from New York to
Seattle and everywhere in between your
acts of selflessness and sacrifice and
ingenuity or powerful testament to the
American character it's really being
shown it's really showing up at a level
that people are really respecting all
over the world they're respecting and
the world has problems 148 countries now
148 countries are affected by the
invisible scourge invisible scourge
there it is that all of the uplifting
reflections greater spirit are out there
for everyone to see together we will
care for our fellow citizens and we will
win this war and we'll win it much
sooner than people think and we'll be
back in business as a country pretty
soon you'll be hearing about that also
pretty soon now I'd like to ask Attorney
General Bill Barr to say a few words and
we'll take questions in a little while
thank you will bar talk about how he's
looking to suspend habeas corpus to keep
people in prison indefinitely jail
rather without trial let me start by
thanking you mr. president mr. vice
president for your decisive leadership
in this unprecedented battle to save
American imagine that the Department of
Justice we're working hard to protect
the health and safety of our personnel
at the same time keeping our enforcement
efforts at full throttle so I'd like to
thank all of my colleagues and law
enforcement not just those at the
federal level but of all our state and
local partners the police officers the
sheriff's deputies who are protecting
and serving their communities often it a
great risk to themselves what I'd like
to do here is start with a few remarks
about the order that the president
mentioned to ensure the availability of
critical medical and health supply
element ordered medical and price
gouging on March 18th the president
issued executive order 3909 invoking the
defense production act with respect to
the health and medical resources needed
to respond to the spread of cocoa vat19
including PPE and ventilators we have
started to see some evidence of
potential hoarding and price gouging and
so earlier today the president signed a
second executive order providing the
authority to address if it becomes
necessary hoarding that threatens the
supply of those necessary health and
medical resources under section 102 of
the defense production Act the president
is authorized to prohibit the hoarding
of needed resources by designating those
materials as scarce or as materials
whose supply would be threatened by
persons accumulating excessive amount
once specific materials are so
designated persons are prohibited from
accumulating those items in excess of
reasonable personal or business needs or
for the purpose of selling them in
excess of prevailing market prices it is
a crime to engage in prohibited activity
in today's executive order the president
is delegating to the Secretary of HHS
this authority to protect against
hoarding by designating these critical
items no items have been designated yet
and the Department of Justice is going
to be working with HHS to identify cases
where a hoarding may be impeding the
supply of health and medical resources
needed to respond to the Cova 19 that is
the right descending today we convened
our first task force meeting a national
task force that will be working on these
supply chain issues and specifically on
the problem of hoarding and price
gouging and we are designating in each
of our 93 United States Attorneys
offices a lead prosecutor who will be
responsible in that district for
pursuing these cases I also want to say
that we have not waited for this order
to be signed we as we have received
evidence recently we have already
initiated investigations of activities
that are disrupting the supply chain and
suggestive of hoarding I want to stress
that we're not talking about consumers
or businesses stockpiling supplies for
their own operations we're talking about
people hoarding these goods and
materials on an industrial scale for the
purpose of manipulating the market and
ultimately deriving windfall profits if
you are have a big supply of toilet
paper in your house this is not
something you have to worry about oh
good we're sitting on it
on a warehouse with masks surgical masks
you will be hearing a knock on your door
so with that mr. president thank you
thanks Bill
[Music]
this may be the most relevant president
just to start I want to really thank all
the ministers of health around the world
who have been sending us their data
despite the fight that they're in
themselves particularly our European
colleagues they continue to send us
primarily their mortality data which is
really very critical because when you're
in the midst of this level of fight that
many of the European countries are
following mortality data will give you
the best insight right now on how the
epidemic is proceeding in those
countries because they really can't be
testing at the level to really
understand the depth and breadth of
their new cases in the mortality data
that has been provided to us there has
been no child under 15 that has
succumbed to the virus in Europe there
was the one 14 year old in China so we
still see that there is less severity
and children and so that should be
reassuring to the moms and dads out
there to Generation Z and to my
millennial colleagues who have been
really at the forefront of many of these
responses less than 1% of all the
mortality is less than 50 and so this is
I think also a very important point that
doesn't mean that individuals won't have
severe disease so still 99 percent of
all the mortality coming out of Europe
in general is over 50 and pre-existing
conditions the pre-existing condition
piece still holds in Italy with the
majority of the mortality having three
or more pre-existing conditions I think
this is reassuring to all of us but it
doesn't change the need to continue to
protect the elderly and in order to
protect the elderly we all need to
continue to do the president's
directives and guidance for the nine
week of the 15 day challenge finally I
wanted to really close by thanking the
laboratory personnel that have been at
the frontlines 250,000 tests have been
run in the last seven days this happened
because these large commercial
laboratories are doing round-the-clock
runs and remember it all of them being
are being exposed to the virus in the
same way from the swabs yet tirelessly
they have worked on and on to get those
results available they are still getting
more tests than they can run per day
that's because we were primarily
expanded into the what we call the Roche
high-throughput tri core machine those
results have been getting to the clients
and we've asked them to prioritize
hospitalized patients there was a
breakthrough today and I think you'll
see this from the FDA in for all of
those who you are waiting for self
swabbing options those are going to be
available there in some time this week
to be able to individuals do their own
tests that said remember these platforms
are keeping up with those who need to be
diagnosed in the hospitals and all those
who come to the emergency room quite ill
so that hospital beds can be freed up
for those that don't have kovat so that
will be critical that if you don't need
a test and if it doesn't change your
clinical course do not come in to be
tested and I think you that mortality
data that I get gave you should be very
reassuring to all of you finally to
conclude New York City the New York
metro area of New Jersey in New York
City and parts of Long Island have an
attack rate close to one in a thousand
this is five times what the other areas
are seeing there through the high
throughput lab investigations we're
finding that 28% of the submitted
specimens are positive from one area
where it's less than 8% and the rest of
the country so to all of my friends and
colleagues in New York this is the
groove that needs to absolutely social
distance and self isolate at this time
clearly the virus had been circulating
there for an
of weeks to have this level of
penetrance into the general community
her statement was okay today Thank You
mr. president
the White House coronavirus task force
met today but we also convened at the
president's direction a conference call
with the nation's governors and we
focused on efforts at mitigation at
testing and supplies we discussed the
president's recent approval of disaster
declarations for Washington and
California and New York but we also
assured governor's who've submitted
major disaster declarations that we will
be reviewing them in an expeditious
manner to ensure the full resources the
federal government are brought to bear
the president wanted us to make it clear
that the federal government will do
whatever it takes to support an effort
that is locally executed state managed
and federally supported we have
reiterated that to our governor's today
listen to them about their specific
needs we're decide and frankly made it
clear to them that while the president
has published at coronavirus gov however
they want to slow the spread for every
American and millions of Americans are
addressing these common-sense guidelines
and to prevent the spread of the corona
virus in the days ahead we made it clear
to the governor's that this president
and this administration fully supports
decisions that governors are making in
communities and states that are
particularly impacted by the spread of
the corona virus and we are grateful for
their efforts we also spoke to the
governor's about the importance of the
legislation that is currently being
negotiated on Capitol Hill and asked
them to encourage members of the House
and the Senate to move very quickly the
bill that is currently being negotiated
the president said that he believes will
be resolved soon and we're encouraged by
it will speed direct payments to
families the average family of four will
receive $3,000
correctly there'll be payroll subsidies
for small businesses around America to
keep people on the payroll while they
might be required to stay home
unemployment insurance benefits
assistance to hospitals and major
industries and we continue to urge the
Congress to act
notice how weirdly Trump stands kind of
like hinged forward if you see it from
the side it's weird predictive testing
we reiterated our thanks to states
across the country that are rapidly
expanding testing it at drive-through
sites and at community sites and as as
dr. Burks just reflected because of the
because of the unprecedented public and
private partnership that the president
initiated with our commercial labs we
stand here today with three hundred and
thirteen thousand tests having been
completed with the test results
delivered to Americans and still
somewhat more than 41,000 have
contracted Corona a virus but this
state-run effort is continuing to
receive the full support of our team at
FEMA and at the US Public Health Service
we're deploying personnel we're
deploying resources and testing is
literally expanding around the country
by the hour as doctor burse also
mentioned the FDA has been in the
process of reviewing less invasive
methods of testing the President and I
both reflected on the fact that that we
have been tested and we've been working
with the FDA to to make it possible for
self collected nasal swabs where
individuals could at the end of their
nasal passage collect a sample and I'm
pleased to report that that self
collected swabs can now be collected in
clinics and it drive through testing
sites this will expedite the testing
process of course but it will also
reduce the risk to health care providers
and for exposure to the corona virus and
it will minimize the drain on personal
protective equipment with the current
tests that
was pretty significantly up the nasal
passage people have to wear gear and
then change out the gear and this new
self-administered tests will actually
not require the drain that's true it's
racial protective equipment and it's all
a part of our effort as as Admiral of
check will discuss in just a few more
people are pointing out in the chat that
you want to make sure that that test is
just as accurate but to meet them with
efforts at conservation as well on the
subject of testing it's important to
remember as the old book says it is not
the healthy who need a doctor but the
sick and so if you don't have symptoms
you don't need to get a coronavirus test
we encourage every American to adhere to
that so that the testing resources are
available for people that are
symptomatic we also will be issuing
today from Health and Human Services new
guidance to direct all commercial labs
to prioritize testing for hospitalized
patients and that guidance is going out
tonight we also reminded the governor's
today that all state laboratories all
hospital laboratories are now required
by law to report the results of
coronavirus tests to the CDC on the
subject of supplies in our meeting today
at FEMA we received a report of the new
supply chain stabilization task force
Rear Admiral John Paul of check is
leading that up at FEMA and the task
force is is working to identify medical
supplies that exist in the marketplace
today to evaluate the national stockpile
and also working with industries around
the country to produce even more of the
critical medical supplies and as the
president said businesses across America
are stepping up and maybe as never
before in our history 3m in fact has
diverted 500,000 n95 masks from
commercial customers and they're being
delivered today to New York and Seattle
Facebook we would acknowledge has
donated their emergency reserve of over
700
and 95 mass to healthcare workers and
these are just a few examples of the
generosity of businesses we're also
seeing companies step forward to
repurpose their manufacturing facilities
to create a lane that Facebook a company
of 40,000 employees has 700,000 masks
given that they run a social network it
is it's interesting we also discussed
with the governor's a real breakthrough
on the availability of ventilators we
called on the governor's to serve at all
survey all outpatient surgical centers
and hospital operating rooms because
surgical ventilators that acini
anesthesiologists use because of an FDA
decision rendered this last weekend
those can be easily converted now to
ventilators that can be used for people
struggling with severe illness from the
coronavirus and so we called on our
governor's in conversations with state
leaders to survey all of their surgical
centers and hospital operating rooms to
identify that equipment and with the new
FDA guidelines they'll be able to
convert those to meet help meet the
needs of ventilators across the country
we are now eight days into the
president's 15 days to slow the spread
and the American people are rising to
the challenge we're doing this but in
the days that remain between now and the
end of the 15 days we're gonna need
every American to take this seriously
listen to your state and local health
authorities where there may be
additional and stronger guidance in
areas where the coronavirus spread has
been more severe but for every American
know that the part that you do that your
family does that you do and your
community to put into practice these
principles of social distancing using a
drive-thru at the local restaurant will
make an enormous difference in in
lowering the trajectory of the corona
virus spreading across our country it's
going to take all of us but with the
ongoing cooperation of the American
people with compassion with the
ingenuity of American industry with
dedicated leadership at the state and
federal level I know
that we can slow the spread we can
protect our most vulnerable and we will
heal our land thanks Mike
Admiral please John polo check
I'm the supply chain Task Force lead at
FEMA my task is to increase the supply
of critical medical supplies which
include personal protective equipment
and ventilators items like that I just
want to take a few moments to explain
the organization that we've stood up
this week this last few days and our
approach so you have a chart behind I
mean I have a focused to focus leads one
on personal protective equipment built
medical supplies and a focused lead on
ventilators operating under four lines
of effort first line of effort you see
is preservation and leaders tonight I've
talked about that ability to make our
stuff last longer
acceleration we have a team of people
that are searching the globe for
personal protective equipment figuring
out where it is figure out if we need to
buy it or just transport it and get it
here faster we have a line of effort
called reallocation we're working with
our industry partners to illuminate the
supply chain there many vendors many
distributors all on separate system
nobody has one sight picture for that
supply chain we've brought our industry
partners in we're weaving that together
to make better allocation decisions and
understand where it is and where it
needs to go we having a line called
expansion you've heard some of that
today if if those that have wanted to
convert plants those that want to get
turning to talk quietly have the tools
to help them to go do that two focus
areas right now PPE and ventilators four
lines of effort
working the problem of the task to get
more here increases today cross 100 for
the first time this morning near Surgeon
General on the Today Show's said he
wanted Americans to understand that this
is gonna get really bad do you share
that prognosis of course I do it's gonna
be bad and we have a lot of people dying
from the flu as you know we have a very
bad flu season on top of everything else
it's very bad it looks like it could be
over 50,000 and certainly this is gonna
be bad and we're trying to make it so
that it's much much less bad and that's
what we're doing I think we're doing a
very good job of it if you look at other
countries what they've been through and
you look at the kind of numbers and
compare them to ours which is a much
larger there just a week ahead that's
all the numbers are pretty amazing and
it started with the fact that we stopped
people from coming in from a highly
affected area and and infected area and
that was a good thing to do so yeah it's
bad and it's going to obviously the
numbers are going to increase with time
and then they're going to start to
decrease and we're going to be opening
our country up for business because our
country is meant to be open and working
with others but especially for our
workers and the engine for that whole
system is we have to have companies and
these companies are loved by our workers
because they're paying big salaries and
big big dollars to our workers and we're
gonna get it all going again very soon
hopefully very very soon please sir I'm
just trying to reconcile the two things
you just said one
things are gonna be very very bad and to
that you want to get the country open
back up as quickly as possible so I
guess my question is if in a week dr.
Burks or about about er telling you we
need to continue these measures for the
health of the vulnerable populations of
the country are you gonna say I'm sorry
the economy is too important what you'll
see what happens I understand the
question very well it's a it's a great
question but not nasty we can do two
things at one time I will say this our
country's learned a lot we've learned
about social distancing we've learned
about the hands we've learned about
staying away at least during the time
that this is even a little bit around
this disease or whatever you want to
call it many different names you can go
up many different names but the virus
while it's around and we can start
thinking about as an example parts of
our country are very lightly affected
very small numbers and you know you look
at a state great governor Pete Ricketts
in Nebraska you look at the kind of
numbers they have out there they have
one of the great one of the great
hospitals there - relative to what we're
talking about but you look at Nebraska
you look at I know you look at Iowa you
look at many places have no people of
course you've got to consider where the
focal points are first and then also per
capita affected to the same extent or
frankly not even nearly to the extent of
New York which is really I'm dealing
with Governor Cuomo and we're dealing
very well together we'll we'll be
sending that ship up by the way as you
know we worship going to Los Angeles
will also be the ship is coming out of a
very large repair so ready to go at
first very soon will be anybody noticed
bars weirdly twitching where his left
eye will open at the same time that the
left side of his mouth kind of flips
it's weird working on that right now
maybe dr. Burks can speak to this do you
share the president's optimism that a
week we might have a situation where we
can say you know there's a few hot spots
well I didn't say really what I said
soon it's going to be soon it's not
gonna be three he's not gonna let her
talk is it some people were saying and a
lot of people thought originally but I
would certainly let you let's see what
she says
say rates to important issues one I
think you all know a lot of our tests
have had to go to hospitals at this time
so that we can diagnose people who are
at risk to give them options to get
these new therapeutic options none of
these therapeutic options are available
if you don't know your diagnosis so
we've been very much focused on that
with adding abbott Therma Fisher illogic
and now I'm Cepheid platforms Sofia is
that new platform that is point-of-care
but slower so you know you got to match
the throughput the need to what kind of
equipment you have now that we have all
those platforms moving simultaneously we
can go back to doing case finding and
surveillance in the areas that have the
most lower numbers as well as doing
mitigation more aggressively in the
places that have higher numbers we went
out with a very blunt force I mean we
have to all be honest we had to do that
because we weren't sure where the virus
was how the state was doing knowing I
think over this week we're concentrated
on figuring out exactly where the virus
is and making projections about where
it's going and the impact of our
mitigation pieces we learned this and in
tackling epidemics around the world you
have to focus the resources and the
intervention and the structural
prevention interventions in the areas
where the virus is circulating otherwise
people never understand why you're doing
this and they don't have any virus so it
has to be very tailored geographically
and it may have to also be very tailored
by age group really understanding who's
at the greatest risk and understanding
how to protect them
so in three months as the president said
we won't need broad topologies the only
data that we all have and I think you
all know what it is the two areas that
have moved through their curve is China
and South Korea so those are the two
countries that we're learning from those
were eight to ten week
curves each state in each hotspot in the
United States is going to be its own
curve because the seeds came in at
different times so Washington State is
on their curve there about two weeks
ahead of new and so each of these have
to be in a very granular way to really
understand where we are and it's the
charge that the president has given us
is to use all of our data analytics and
all of our data inputs to really define
those issues about where the virus is
where is it going and what predictions
we can make about when where we are in
that bell-shaped curve I think it's a
great definition and I will say we're
going to be watching our senior citizens
very closely we're going to be watching
certain hotspots like New York and
within New York you have areas which are
troubling and we'll be working with the
governor and the mayor and everybody
else on those spots but at the same time
at a certain point we have to get open
and we have to be we have to get moving
we don't want to lose these companies we
don't want to lose these workers we want
to take care of our workers so we'll be
doing something I think relatively
quickly but we've learned a lot during
this period this was a very necessary
period tremendous information was gained
but we can do two things at one time you
know and again I say we have a very
active flu season more active than most
it's looking like it's heading to 50,000
or more death enough nutcases
50,000 deaths which is that's a lot and
you look at automobile accidents which
are far greater than any numbers with oh
my goodness
we're going to tell everybody no more
driving of cars so what a terrible
analogy is to get our country open but
this has been an incredible period of
learning and we'll have announcements
over the next fairly short period as to
the timing John please ask about these
guidelines on testing obviously Senator
Rand Paul has tested positive for a crow
no question but he was not in contact
with anybody who was known positive and
he didn't have any major symptoms under
your guidelines one of the guidelines
that have been outlined here he would
not have gotten a test right he got one
anyway so what do you say to him he's
pointed out that if he hadn't gone
basically in defiance of these
guidelines and got tested he might still
be showing up to the Senate right now
and inviting the whole u.s. that
somebody else is gonna have to deal with
that that's why this was important
that's why this recommendation to the
American people was important because we
have been saying that there is a level
of asymptomatic or mild spread and
that's why each person has to be
responsible each person has to be
responsible in the way that they
decrease their interaction with others
the six-feet you're all very social
distance so thank you but also as
they're all standing together everyone
that you're interacting with could be
positive and that gets into the
hand-washing piece and that gets into
the other piece we talked about is
surfaces I think until we really figure
out the respiratory transmission versus
the surface transmission and this hard
surface transmission not fabric will be
really critical because that is a way
the virus could spread on subways or
metros where people would be holding on
to things that other people had recently
held on to so that's the real question
obviously there are many other people
that would be in similar that just keep
with this one example if he hadn't
gotten that test he would still be
showing up
and to the Senate every day at his place
of work if he advises guidelines he
wouldn't have been infecting others
because of the social distancing washing
your hands doing everything that we
talked about so we've talked about also
how people make choices because of their
jobs that they have to come in you'll
notice I was not here over the weekend I
think this is the part that we really
need to take personal responsibility for
Saturday had a little low-grade fever Oh
No
so actually probably a GI thing but you
know I'm why she's in position
I won't give up I ended up piggy bank
I'm from Walter Reed so I got a test
late Saturday night and I'm negative I
stayed home another day Justin this is
getting weird guys I'm not gonna lie
sure that's how we protect one another
so you know unless everybody's taking
their temperature every day we can't say
that he has going on the kinds of things
that we have to do for one another this
is the personal responsibility that I'm
talking about that we all have to
practice the cure to be worse than the
bra on the self so are you saying that
if we kept these measures that we're
doing now in place for a couple of
months - well they won't be in place at
some point we're gonna open up our
country and it's gonna be fairly soon
weeks or months I'm not looking I'm not
looking at months I can tell you right
now we're gonna be opening up our
country and we're gonna be watching
certain areas and we're gonna be
practicing everything that Deborah's
referring to right here we're gonna be
watching this very closely but you can't
keep it closed for the next you know
four years okay this is going away we're
we're gonna win the battle but we also
have you know you have tremendous
responsibilities we have jobs we have
people get tremendous anxiety and
depression and you have suicides over
things like this when you have terrible
economies you
of death probably and I mean definitely
would be in far greater numbers than the
numbers that we're talking about with
regard to the virus so we have an
obligation we have a double obligation
we have a great country there's no
country like it in the world and there's
no economy like it in the world I mean
we had we were we were just blazing we
were coming out with numbers that some
numbers weren't even reported because it
was already this had happened they were
meaningless I got numbers about myself
that were meaningless because by the
time the numbers came in you know it's a
whole different world with this but I
will tell you that we can do both things
John we can do them both at the same
time I mean that's okay what we have
gone through is a tremendous learning
process and we've also solved a lot of
problems but we've gone through a
tremendous learning problem you know
situation now we're building hospitals
in New York we're building hospitals in
California we're building hospitals in
the state of Washington we've been in
touch with the governor's today I spoke
with a man that I happened to like I
spoke with Phil in New Jersey and where
we're going to be doing something very
meaningful in New Jersey we're doing
something I spoke with JB Pritzker
called me today we're gonna be helping
them out in Illinois we're doing a lot
of things in Florida we're doing a lot
of things and between FEMA and the Army
Corps of Engineers and the Admiral in
your group in terms of the purchasing
this does seem like an asset is supposed
to be great I'll tell you about two days
but he's gonna do a fantastic job so we
have an incredibly talented group of
people but yeah we'll be doing two
things and three things at one time well
at the same time though we're gonna be
watching very closely the hot spots
we're going to be taking care and
watching very closely our senior
citizens especially those with a problem
or an illness we're gonna be watching as
this tragic incompetent and we can do
that and have an open economy have an
open country and we have to do that
because that causes other problems and
maybe it causes much bigger problems
than the problem we're talking about now
you understand
mr. president following up on that same
topic in under tweet do you think that
picture so far has been worse than the
problem
I think the cure has been very tough
this has been a very tough this was an
operation we've done nothing somebody
going to a doctor and saying you need an
operation and we've had an operation
we've learned a lot and we fixed a lot
of problems one of the things we fixed
if you look at the absolute system that
this administration inherited it wasn't
meant for this it was meant for a small
group of people and even for that it was
not very good and very obsolete we now
have a testing city we have a testing
program now that will hopefully be able
to be used for many years into the
future should we have another event like
this I don't think you'll have another
event like this this is very unique you
look but I'll never happen again you're
not kids in decades we can name a mall
even if you go back 10 years you know
you go back to oh 9 but that wasn't like
this as it turned out but they lost a
lot of people we were early we were
early Jeff because of the fact that we
closed early that was a big move please
Chris yeah go ahead you know the you had
said previously I think from this podium
the virus could still be with us through
July or August by suggesting now that
reminder that the government might
change these standards or these
recommendations change it's no we're
doing things this was a learning
experience to the people of the country
and even famous has changed for you the
table has changed the July August time
frame of what do you think the virus
would be under control I think we've
learned a lot I think that there's so
much discipline now that we never had
nobody ever said don't shake hands I did
actually before it became a politician
once it became a politician then it's
hard getting used to not doing it
because you know you do it with
everybody with literally thousands of
people a week you're shaking hands with
big groups of people and you know we've
there's a lot of we've learned a lot
there's a great discipline that this
whole country has learned having to do
with distancing having to do with
shaking hands I think a lot of its gonna
stay long after the viruses gun I really
think it's probably good practice anyway
but I think it's gonna stay long after
the virus is gone but we can we have to
open our country because that causes
problems that in my opinion could be far
bigger problems far bigger this look
this is a medical severe medical
elevation that could cause problems far
beyond the medical and then increase the
medical problems to things that had
nothing to do with this original medical
problem we can't let that happen to our
country we have the greatest country in
the world I'm not gonna let that happen
but this two weeks that we have spent
has been an incredible learning period
and process please Christopher
that's the Kayla nut of any of the
doctors on your team told you that's the
right path to pursue we spoke to him
today and I was telling them that we
have two things to look for don't forget
the doctors if it were up to the doctors
they may say let's keep it shut down
let's shut down the entire world because
again you're up to almost 150 countries
so let's shut down the entire world and
when we shut it down that would be
wonderful let's keep it shut for a
couple of years you know I can't do that
and you can't do that with a country
especially the number one economy
anywhere in the world by far number one
economy in the world can't do that
because well it causes bigger problems
than the original that's why I talk
about the cure being worse than the
problem we can't have the Cure be worse
than the problem but what we have done
so this is not retracing this isn't it
that we've done it really well because
this two-week period has been good and
I'm not saying it ends at that time you
know we have another seven days or so
I'm not saying it ends at that time but
I am saying certainly it's been like
this incredible learning process that's
going to go into the future that's going
to go even as we open up our country and
we're going to be watching New York and
we're going to be watching California
we're gonna be watching the state of
Washington and other places Allah noise
becoming a hot spot and we can do we can
do both now we may quarantine I mean we
will be quarantine quarantine and many
people in these areas there are other
areas that just aren't affected or
they're affected very little and why
would we close down a hundred percent of
the country there are areas within New
York where New York will be open but
there are areas within New York
remember this New York has the New York
Stock Exchange it has Nasdaq it has the
exchanges to close the New York Stock
Exchange and Nasdaq and all of with all
of the great work they're doing I mean
they've gone largely to computer you
look at the floor it's incredible what
they can do but it's computers these
days but this isn't the same guys so we
can do what I'm saying basically is that
we can do two things
this is mania simultaneously and we've
had this in
Plus people have been in a period and
they won't be calling oh gee because
I've got many many people that now come
to me and say we get it we think we can
really do it now and do it while we're
open so at some point we'll be setting
some guidelines we'll be setting some
date lines
we'll be announcing them and they're not
too distant future we talk together and
I think they're ok with it and I'm ok
with it but this could be a much bigger
problem this could create a much bigger
problem than the problem that you start
off with yes called the relations do
what they're going to do but they'll
probably do something very similar but
in our case much more so than anywhere
else because of the magnitude of our
economy the tremendous size of what
we've built and what we have and the
jobs involved you know you have 160
almost 160 million jobs in this country
now the most ever by far by far the most
ever the number of jobs almost a hundred
and 60 million so we can't turn that off
and think it's going to be wonderful
there'll be tremendous repercussions
there will be a tremendous death from
that death you know you're talking about
death probably more death I'm not
working anything that we're talking
about with respect to the virus oh my
goodness we continue with these strict
guidelines than if we ease them
no I think we're gonna do them both I
think what that's what I'm saying I
think we can do them both now we haven't
announced the date but we're getting
fairly close to coming up with a date
and it's a much shorter period of time
than I've been hearing the news report
and I think everybody should be happy
with that but great knowledge was gained
please I had two questions for you mr.
president my second one is on what your
economic adviser Larry Kudlow said today
he was talking about this and he said
that they were going after make some
difficult trade-offs if you do you mean
with the Democrats you know no no he was
saying he was talking about how you said
you know the cure should be worse than
the problem and he was talking about
reopening the businesses getting the
economy going back and going again what
are those difficulties true I mean have
you said if I didn't hear him say that
but if he said difficult trade-off sure
it's less convenient before you walk and
you hop in the subway and you grab the
handle and you go down to wherever
you're going on Wall Street and you do
all sorts of things right and and you
open the doors going into you agree no
no no no the exchanges and now you're
not gonna have to maybe think about
doing that or you're gonna think about
doing it a different way no no there are
many trade-offs it's a different life
and maybe it'll remain that way frankly
after he doesn't get it the invisible
scourge his gun to say that way not a
bad thing to say that way but know there
are trade-offs there's no question about
that but I actually think it's gonna I
think in the end we're gonna end up
being bigger better and stronger we have
learned a lot please we're seeing an
increase of pieces in Latin America and
the millions true in this is in Asia are
you considering a new round of travel
ban no we're not really something like
that could happen I guess but we're not
really they thought we were gonna have
bans within the United States we didn't
do that we're not gonna have that
hopefully that'll take care of itself no
one's in Latin America there is a
there's been an uptick yeah please
a second question what prompt you to say
at the bidding of your beginning of your
comments that you're gonna take care of
the Asian Americans living something in
particular at that was yeah because it
seems that there could be a a little bit
of nasty language toward the Asian
Americans in our country and I don't
like that at all beautiful big
incredible people they love our country
and I'm not gonna let it happen so I
just wanted to make that point because
they're blaming just a giant China and
they are making statements to great
American citizens that happen to be of
Asian heritage and I'm not gonna let
that happen please Wow thank you want to
reopen the country but most schools
across the country are closed two states
now are closed for the rest of the
school year
how are parents supposed to go back to
work and educate their yeah the
governors of the various states will
have a lot of leeway if we open up and
when we open up the governors in certain
states for instance you go to some of
the states I just mentioned those
schools are gonna be open many cases
they're open now but the schools are
gonna be open in other cases governor
cuomo gavin newsom of california certain
governors are going to maybe have a
decision to make now they may make a
decision to keep them open in a certain
part of New York and maybe in
Westchester County or wherever it may be
they'll keep them closed but they're
gonna have leeway we give me the
governor's a lot of leeway decision to
close it several months out at this
point these governors are saying they're
expecting a peak in the next couple of
months and it made a decision and the
governor's ever make those decisions
that's going to be up to the governors
and they're very capable they'll be able
to make the decisions please sir you
explain why two trillion dollar economic
stimulus is needed if you are going
through the country and a period of
weeks not months because the virus has
had a big impact on our country so we're
going to give a stimulus so that the
workers bigpac and live their life it
was not their fault it wasn't the
workers fault and we are going to give a
a kick so that it's a kick and this way
we think the workers can get a fair
start the small businesses were taking
very good care of we want to take care
of these small businesses they really
are the engine of this country a lot of
people don't know that you know everyone
thinks of these great big beautiful
businesses who by the way have been very
badly hurt also but these small
businesses have really historically been
the engine and they still are the engine
of the country and you'd be amazed the
workers love those businesses and the
workers contact us and they want us to
help those businesses because that's
where they've made their living that's
where they you know they've been paid a
lot of money over the years and you know
you've been seeing what's happened over
the last three years where salaries and
wages have gone up very substantially
for those workers life and then we got
caught by this sudden craziness coming
into our country and coming all over the
world so we need to make sure that the
companies are strong and that the
workers are strong and that's what we're
doing and notice no mentions of Chinese
virus and no blaming of China so far
they're gonna be able to make a deal and
they're actually fairly close but we'll
see what happens please - Trillian
dollar says my question one of the
things you have to save companies that
have been shattered you're gonna have to
save various I mean you you know a lot
of the companies yourselves we have a
company that was I think the greatest
company in the world named Boeing
Boeing's gonna need some help
now Boeing had some difficulty before
that's unlike others we have other
countries companies that didn't have a
problem coming and Boeing had the
obvious problem that everybody knows
about from a little more than a year ago
a double problem and it was a boy
and then on top of it as they're getting
ready to really show their stuff on top
of it we all get hit by this and
obviously the airlines are gonna have a
problem but the airlines aren't gonna be
buying from Boeing or from anybody else
right now because of this this
difficulty so we have to work with the
airlines we have to work with the cruise
lines we have to work with the companies
like a Boeing because Boeing's a
potentially again a great company at a
very rough period of 13 months a very
rough period a horrible period an
unbelievable period if you would have
told me this would have happened to
Boeing I wouldn't have believed it
because to me was you know truly one of
the great one of the truly great
probably almost 1 point of GDP if you
can think of that's hard to believe that
a company could have that kind of an
impact but Boeing we have to work with
it for two reasons some one it's a great
company that we have to save number two
it produces unbelievable numbers of jobs
and so you know the numbers have to be
reflective of that kind of function rap
you know what I'm gonna do we have
wonderful people behind us that are
working very hard and we want bill to
get back to the Department of Justice so
we want the Admiral to start going and
doing your job and and the same thing
with Deb if anybody would have any
questions maybe I'll ask Mike to stay
around but if anybody would have any
questions for the group and otherwise
I'll let them go back to work we see
talking about different geographical
slopes on this to curve we'd be changing
and yet you just said that 20 percent
numbers coming out of New York give us
an indication that we don't quite know
when the seeds to use your your metaphor
were planted so how confident are you on
the start dates of each curve for each
of the geographical area very good
question presents needs to be indicating
will be adjusting the policy for so
that's a very good question so what we
do know is how we can backtrack from
people who get very seriously ill to
when they probably got infected this is
when they were exposed and so when you
start backing out each of those pieces
when you start seeing hospitalized
patients you know that the virus has
probably been there for three to four
weeks substantially circulating within
the
so that's what we're looking for now as
all of our testing is improved and we
want to really applaud the group who has
worked on it you know if you look at the
pandemic flu preparedness all of this
was built on a flu platform it was never
ever thought that you'd have a
simultaneous respiratory disease hitting
at exactly the same time as your flu
hits in the country and so when you're
doing all of your flu surveillance you
could hide small cases of these
pneumonias and flu-like illnesses
characterized as a flu-like illness for
the last four to six weeks and so that's
really a caution to all of us and so
when we get through all of this we'll be
looking at each of the pandemic
preparedness plans a long way of saying
we know Washington state is a little bit
ahead of New York because of the
hospitalization records what we will get
to as a country with the naana testing
that will be available is being able to
do what the president talked about
simultaneously simultaneously doing
containment contract tracing at the same
time you're doing mitigation and I think
right now we put everything into
mitigation yet if we geographically get
specific data by zip codes and counties
we'll be able to approach this in a very
laser focused way making sure that what
we're doing in each of those areas
they're being encoded salutely
appropriate for where they are in their
own little bell-shaped curve
when will the government roll out the
people who know beautiful question does
so all a several of them have come to
the FDA
I believe obviously that's something I
am very interested in for two reasons
one it will give us a retrospective on
where these infections were who was
actually infected and how really
asymptomatic versus mild versus all of
that comes into the spectrum secondly by
people who have high titers of those
antibodies those can become our solution
with plasmapheresis for those in need
and the in the making of hyper immune
globulin so knowing who they are becomes
really critical yeah but I think we're
still a couple of weeks out I have to go
back and talk to the FDA where each of
these are because this is what saved us
with when you do flu swabs when you do
threats strep throat swabs and now where
you could do an HIV test so these are
the kinds of tests that we know will be
critical in the future I wanted to say
one other thing because you see a lot of
numbers out there about 70% of the
population is going to get infected or
60% of the population based on those
models understand that the way you get
to that number is you do nothing and it
goes through three cycles so they're
talking about this cycle that we're
currently and another cycle in 2021 and
a third cycle in 21 22 in order to get
that level of population infected and
you know we will have vaccines most
likely by the 2122 season and we're
going to hopefully have therapeutics in
the fall of the next season so the
reason we're so much focused on blunting
the curve for this piece is if if the
virus comes back we'll have much more
facility both for diagnosis testing
monoclonal antibodies treatments and
then the backs
so a question about the serology blood
tests where some people said hope hold
some real promise here when will those
be FDA approved and when would they be
widely available so that's what she was
just asking about so these IgG is an IgM
both point-of-care I can tell you it
would be no problem making Eliza today
but then you're drawing blood you're
processing blood you're running plates
that's what we did in the past we really
want a finger prick type assay where you
can just put a finger prick on and get
your IgG and IgM so that's what we're
working on until that's approved and
available with you I can't answer
because I have to look at where each of
the companies are that are in their
development processes well there's some
that are developed now that they were
using in Singapore so we're looking at
those to see how those work so we're
looking at those but you know we're very
quality oriented because we want to make
sure we don't give people false
negatives or false positives I have a
question for you so we have a lot of
very angry media all around this room oh
and they want one of these seats but
because of social distancing we are
keeping them empty and they are keeping
them empty will there ever be a time
when all of those really angry angry
people who don't like me much to start
off with but now they really don't like
me will there ever be a time when these
seats are full like full to the brim
like it used to be where people are
almost sitting on each other's lap and
this whole row over here is packed and
now they're outside wanting to get in
and they're very jealous of all of these
reporters will we ever have that again
or is that something that will be you
know it'll look like this forever so
we're learning a lot about social
distancing and respiratory diseases oh
boy
and I think those are the discussions we
had to have in the future it was what
you were talking about changing our
whole behavior patterns of what we touch
and being constant
of that I remember when I was worried
Saturday morning I was trying to think
what all did I touch on Friday did I
touch a doorknob did I do this don't I
do that
did I not wash my hands I mean you go
through this whole piece that I touch my
face by accident so I think this this
awareness that we all now have it's not
gonna answer before where we would have
pushed through that door or to turn that
doorknob because we were in such a hurry
now I think all of us think twice I
think all of you think twice but when
the virus is gone will the people
they'll have to sit next to each other
again in your opinion and it type room
no you have to look and see if we have a
new respiratory piece certainly this is
the way we setup every clinic around the
world when we're worried about TB and TB
transmission less than two people except
for families which is a pretty
restrictive number does that inform your
thinking as you are coming up with
advice for this next period for the
president and vice president the
president and vice president have asked
us to look at every single scenario in
every single country because the more
data we have off coast or more our
decisions can be completely data
informed and really understanding what
impact that has I mean we're interested
right now I mean Italy obviously waited
until about March 7th the virus had been
seriously shot the screens off - were
actually going into that methodology but
for the first time it looks like their
number their mortality rates are
starting to decline which would be an
illustration that things that they did
two and three weeks ago may actually
have an impact those the kinds of data
we're looking at very carefully as well
as very careful data within the United
States of exactly where the virus is
what's the attack rate has it moved out
of its more confined geography and
really looking at each of those pieces
of information it's a lot of data to
well I think if you remember just a week
ago
Britain had a very different approach so
everybody is adapting to their data I
haven't looked at the data that informed
that decision so I can't really comment
on how they got to that decision there
or in Germany it's just to be clear do
you agree with the president's push to
reopen the country he said some of his
doctors that he's talking to about this
he says I think they're okay with it
are you okay with that what the
president has asked us to do is to
assemble all the data and get us give
give him our best medical recommendation
based on all the data that's what he's
asked us to do and so that's what we'll
be doing this week we were going to have
to do it this week anyway because we had
to make a decision
come Monday about the 15 days to reduce
social spreads so this is consistent
with our mandate to really use every
piece of information that we can in
order to give the present and our
opinion that's backed up by data they
are perception but our opinion that's
backed up by data now you think you
could in a week like what would your
assessment be of right now well ours
we're pulling all of the data of the
data and that's really critical
I will never speculate on data right I
will have to see the data in order to do
today to date and I think the fact is
the mortality rate we're talking about
the mortality rate you know when we
first started people were thinking about
three and four percent and now we're
talking about a much lower number than
that I think it's a I think it's a
number that will be a lot different than
people the mortality rate is driven
almost exclusively as we have talked
about by people with pre-existing
conditions and older so that has become
from the very beginning that was our
emphasis you know when we started two or
three weeks ago talking with one another
our focus has been on how do we protect
those with pre-existing conditions and
the elderly and I think these steps were
about protecting with pre-existing is
Trump's gonna unveil a bunch of new
products that are going to be exciting
for coronavirus customers
is not just the hospital care but
preventing them from going into the
hospital to begin with because you don't
need that you want them to be infected I
mean frankly yes well you know what the
estimate would in wuhan was originally
it was over three percent when they look
outside
Wuhan it was about 0.7 percent it
depends very much in South Korea it was
about point seven point eight percent
but I don't want that's like a tyranny
of averages and I you know that's not
having that's probably missing fifty
sixty percent of the data because no one
was testing asymptomatic so remember in
every country you had to be symptomatic
to get a test so we you know we're
making case fatality rates when we're
missing a significant part of the data
so if anything it will go lower but I
don't want it people it don't that
should not be reassuring because the
death rates escalate with age and
pre-existing conditions and I was
looking over well here that L though it
may be very low if you're under 40 or
very low if you're under 50 I'm very low
if you're under seventy there is an
inflection curve there people the
average age of the person's dying in
Italy is in the mid eighties so there is
really a significant issue in our older
generation that we feel strongly about
protecting the doctor this is just very
interesting the whole thing it's an
incredible subject when somebody is very
sick they go to a doctor go to a
hospital they recorded they're very sick
and then they live where they don't live
see what happens but when somebody isn't
very sick at all I've heard people that
they don't even know they had it and
they're healing that I've heard people
they have like a call or they have a
running nose or even people that saw
this is something trumpet at this point
has to ask okay so they think they have
a really bad case of the flu but all of
those people that vast majority of I
mean beyond vast majority of people
they're not reporting they're not
calling the doctor they're not calling
him they're just getting better so you
think it would have to be because the
people that are sick are going to a
doctor or they're going someplace I
think they're saying make me better
people that are just sure that and
people that aren't even I mean many
people where they literally don't even
know that they have it so now you're
building up the number of cases that we
talked about before just learning about
this how many but what you do know is
all the people that are really sick
because all of the people that are
really sick are going to a doctor in
some form and the doctor is reporting it
in all cases so but that's why your
vision about what the antibody test is
so critical because that will give us
really a much better baseline to really
understand so there's several stages on
whether or not we keep these these
guidelines in place you talk about
higher death or you talk about suicide
like help us understand the pressure is
that what you're getting at we're
talking about
look number one it's the country itself
you're talking about tremendous
disruption economically but you're
talking about massive depression massive
numbers of suicides anomic depression
no I'm talking abut no I'm not talking
about economic well though you could be
talking about that too so you what I'm
talking about is oppressed people
suffering massive depression because
they had a fantastic job and now they
have no idea you know what's going on
now here's the good news if they get the
bill passed we're taking care of those
people we're gonna really take good care
of those people beyond what any country
has done for people but there's never
been anything like this no I'm talking
about where people suffer massive
depression I get out when people commit
suicide
where tremendous death happens now in
addition to that we're talking about
economic where you you know really hurt
a country it could take years and years
to recover and the longer you stay out
the harder it is to recover I happen to
think that you're going to have they
call it the V I think you're gonna have
a very big bounce you know very big
bounce back I think it's gonna be very
big we'll see
well I think the bill should pass it
should pass quickly and your take care
of our workers think
the companies that that pay those
workers help those companies over this
rough patch but the longer it takes the
harder it is to come back I'd like to be
able to bounce back to where we were and
ultimately I think we're going to be
even further than that but I'm just
saying that the the what's happening
when I say the cure and the cure could
be worse than the problem itself right
that's what we can't let that happen we
can't let that happen
we've learned so much Wow how many good
things are going to happen for a country
we can't let this continue to go on so
what we're doing is we're meeting with
the doctors dr. Fuji dr. Burks and
others and where we've already started
the discussion and I can say that you
know I'm a student like your students
we're all learning this together I
learned a lot from Debra I learned the
last five minutes Oni I learned a lot
from a lot of people you get the feeling
half of what Trump knows he learned
during this press conference I've
learned a lot we're going to come up
with a date and we're gonna do two
things we can do two things at one time
at the same time we're gonna be very
vigilant we're gonna be so vigilant in
terms of all of the things that we have
to do that we've been talking about for
the last two weeks at nauseam and I
think it's going to be ultimately a far
better solution for our country yeah
please go ahead thank you great job
Thank You Debra they won't let you go in
15 days to slow the spread doesn't talk
of reopening the government quickly
undermine that I mean why would anyone
to
still social distance or not Ranaut
actually enforced it because if people
know that we're considering and trying
to understand the impact of the good
work that they have done I think it
reinforces them to do good work for the
next of whatever it is flat out it all
these weeks in the future because it's
City out of them we're looking very
carefully of the impact that the work
that you did the selflessness that you
brought the ability to stay home with
your fabulous children your ability to
social distance the ability to give up
on going to restaurants and just having
take out all of those sacrifices the
ability of your protecting our elder
generation the greatest generation and
making sure they're safe in nursing
homes but not seeing them all of us have
made sacrifices I haven't seen my
grandchildren in three weeks I know
other people are like that that they
have really made those personal
sacrifices what we're asking every
American to do is to make those personal
sacrifices for these next week and now
so that we can evaluate the impact of
that sacrifice so I think of anything
it's strengthens the willpower to say
yes I can do this thank you
one thing some public officials said
would be helpful is to open back up the
ACA exchanges so that people who are
worried about perhaps getting treatment
could go sign up for insurance now even
though the open enrollment period is
open imagine that's something you can do
with well it is it's something we're
talking to a lot of people about we'll
see what happened Trump might be opening
right now I do know this briefing will
I was just with him we have a test with
me he is there does he agree with you
about the meet when you call me soon
oddities tremendous the doctor there's a
tremendous cost to our country both in
terms of lives and in terms of economics
and in terms of many many years of
rebuilding something that was a
fine-tuned machine there was nobody's
fault it just happened this horrible
virus came from wherever and it just
happened it just happened he fully
understands that no he's a good man I
like doctor foul a lot just so you
understand no he's not here because we
really weren't discussing what he's best
at but he'll be back up very soon yeah
please and we'll be discussing dates and
times of them and we are talking about a
I don't want to use the word abbreviated
because so much has been gained by what
we've done but we're talking about not
during the period you know during the
fourteen or fifteen days but not too
long after that a lot of companies have
it's gonna make a lot of workers happy
yeah Jeff will you take dr. fauci's
recommendation on this or are you
thinking he's just looking at one set of
him I would certainly he's very
important to me and I would I will be
listening to him I'll be listening to
Debra who you just spoke to I'll be
listening to other experts we have Larry
Kudlow people that are very good at this
and ultimately it's a balancing act but
you know the expression we can do two
things at one time and we've got an
incredible country we have to keep it
that way and that includes I'm talking
about reopening half of the Senate might
have the virus within two weeks that way
you're talking about social distancing
amongst us reporters and you mentioned
that one of our own has come down or is
actually come down even if someone does
come down on the White House press corps
which you pledged the American people
that you'll keep this room open we're
clearly six feet apart
well I gotten to like this room this
room is very convenient I can say from
the standpoint of being president of the
United States I really this has been a
very convenient room for all of us you
people have set up so I never even
thought of closing it so you're asking
me a question that I'd never thought in
terms of can you give me a good reason
to close we could build a large
opportunity to see I mean you said I
don't want to make commitments like that
because it's you know not something I've
ever really thought about there are
certain people that would like to see a
larger room built we need a larger room
other presidents didn't need such a
large room but we need a larger room and
there are some people but it's not
something that it's really on my mind to
be honest with you yes big supporter too
we know it's gonna be brutal who are you
listening to where is the brain trust to
help get us through that period and also
has your opinion of the George Barrett
or to the second quarter and Jacob more
than whatever Morgan Stanley Goldman
Sachs they were all predicting a pretty
entire second quarter so who are you
listening to where's the brain trust you
have all these medical I think I think
we're listening too many people I mean
that was my world I know many of those
people they have many people that are
friends of mine some enemies also by the
way but you know it's been a good world
for me I like that world I like those
people they're tough and they're smart
but I listened to many of them
ultimately they all go into that
computer and I say this is really going
to do I have to make a decision this is
a very important man right here to my
right
great whites vice president because he's
got a great instinct about things too so
I'm going to be listening to Mike he's
headed up the task force
I think brilliantly I think it's gonna
go down as that he's infected spraying
away not only has it been good he's been
soothing he's really been great for the
American public to watch it and I mean
that and I mean that in the most
positive way imagine there is a solidity
with Mike
that you don't find in many people he's
been soothing he's been good for the
American public we have confidence in
him I think he's done an incredible job
and his advice is very very important to
me so he's going to be making I mean he
didn't come from that world the world of
finance but he understands the world of
finance he was a great governor in
Indiana money I could give you a whole
list and we'll probably even set up
committees I'd rather not give you one
because then I'm gonna let leave it I
have spoken to so many people I think
he's speaking I really think he's caught
up and he's done the right thing and I
think ultimately we will be rewarded
because of the decision he made over the
list he's really stepped up over the
last week and I have to tell you I
called him today and I said Jerome good
job you really did it it might be he was
you know a little bit slower than I
would have liked in the sense of what he
was doing now other people might have
liked it but today I called up Jerome
Powell and I said Jerome you've done a
really good job I was proud of him I was
that took courage and ultimately you're
gonna see the fruits that he's not
finished I mean he's got other albums
and aquiver or whatever they say I will
tell you he's got plenty of arrows but
no I'm very happy with the job it did
[Music]
that you'd bring the Secretary of
Education here either yesterday or today
why isn't she here then can we expect
for this week also yesterday you said
you mustn't guidance for us some people
who'd potentially been exposed to the
virus returning to work sooner yes
thank you for the question I spoke to
the Secretary of Education today and
we're going to have her at the podium
very soon the Department of Education
has created a very easy waiver
application for every state it's
virtually an automatic application for
states that want to be excused from
national standardized testing
requirements we reviewed that with all
of the governor's today and also what's
called distance learning the
accreditation process for higher
education the Secretary of Education at
the president's urging has has loosened
the rules around distance learning
you're seeing many colleges and
universities embracing distance learning
now putting it into practice we've
allowed for that but also the Department
of Education is setting up a website and
best practices information for K through
12 distance learning and she actually
told me that the state of Florida and
New Hampshire are really setting the
pace on distance learning for k-12 my
wife is an elementary school teacher
obviously there's different different
challenges for distance learning for K
through 12 students particularly younger
kids but the Department of Education is
determined to continue to make those
best practices available we talked about
the website that's being built and
she'll be coming and making a
presentation on that because as the
president reflected a little bit ago as
dr. Burks did we we understand there's a
lot of kids out of school but parents
are anxious a lot of kids out of college
and university like my daughter whose
has been dismissed from the what remains
of this semester of grad school but but
is still doing the work and the
Department of Education is working
earnestly to make that make that a
reality yes I'll have her here this week
she I mean given the issues that we were
dealing with today with the Attorney
General we thought it might be just as
timely in a few days with regard to the
guidance that you asked about the
president's coronavirus task force is in
the process of reviewing recommendations
from CDC we're working with the
Department of Homeland Security we'll be
bringing those to the president as
recommendations of approval we're
specifically looking at people that work
in critical infrastructure people in law
enforcement people in critical
transportation you can go right now to
the Department of Homeland Security's
website for a very useful definition of
critical infrastructure and if you look
at the second page of 15 days to slow
the spread you'll see the president's
recommendation with this 15 days is for
people to stay home from work whenever
possible this is great except for people
working in critical infrastructure and
the guidance that we're looking forward
to unpacking is how people who may have
come into contact with someone that test
positive coronavirus would be able to if
they have no symptoms would be able to
return to work wear a mask for a certain
period of time but otherwise go back to
business it's a focus on critical
infrastructure jobs we should have that
guidance before the president and before
the public tomorrow mr. president we
have understandably that's worker hi I
just want to say well we're thinking
about it China has very much stepped up
as you probably know the agricultural
purchases from our farmers and some
other purchases too so they have a
difficult time also right now but they
very much stepped up their purchases and
significantly so we're very happy about
that the other thing you know I'm
standing here in this case with our vice
president
trying to let you ask anything you want
having to do with the subject which
frankly is pretty much all anyone cares
about right now but because I think was
very important I don't want to stand
here for two hours and do this but I
think it's important that you know I
cook I call it get it out of your system
give us any question about it because I
think it's important for the public to
know so we don't want to answer two
questions and leave we want to answer
your questions that's why we're doing
this for so long and I think it gives
our country confidence and it gives I
think we're giving you know we're all
gaining knowledge this has been informed
unbelievable process but we're all
getting out so I want to you know stay
here sometimes we're here for two hours
and we're answering questions at least
you will say that I'm very transparent
oh boy I think you even have a hard time
saying he is not transparent but we we
take a lot of questions from you
unfortunately some of them are
repetitive and some of them are
fantastic but some are now some of these
questions are great some of the
questions lead to us solving a problem
you bring up problems that people didn't
know existed but I just want to let you
know so we're doing this so that we can
be transparent so that we can get
everything out
yeah go ahead mr. president we have a
patchwork of plans understandably at the
moment are you coordinating an economic
response with the leaders of the g7 yeah
you are we're very very close to him we
had a couple of great talks plus they
speak I've spoken to a number of them
individually yeah we're very very
closely aligned please
available they said this week but do you
know which day and you know where
they're going the FDA just announced
that decision and my understanding is
that they'll be now going directly to
market I'll have a good estimate for you
on on timeline but what the president
has charged us to do at the task force
is to promote as much creativity and as
much innovation as possible
and and frankly dr. Han as the president
said at the FDA stand a remarkable job
going through the review and approval
process for these new methodologies
really in record record time we
reflected a little bit ago about the
fact that we're we're pretty sure we set
a record I think it was 62 days to be in
in the phase 1 clinical trials of a
vaccine that's actually in clinical
trials today but this that's this new
approval from a study done by United
Health Group and the gates group means
that now self collected nasal swabs will
become available we're going to be
working through FEMA with governor's
around the country to make sure and
distribute those those methods as well
as the swabs or any other supporting
material and get those into this vast
array of labs that are now stood up
around the country that's going to make
a big difference because that really is
a process that's easy as opposed to the
current process which is not as I've
said it's not pleasant I just want to
get clarity on this if we get to next
week we're deciding or you're deciding
what to do with these guidelines whether
to ease them or
state them for another 15 days will you
follow the advice of dr. Burks and dr.
FAL - if they say you should maintain
them and others yes then ultimately have
to make a decision but I certainly
listen to them I listen to a number of
people but I have a lot of respect for
dr. pouchy and for dr. Burks
and I'll be listening to them and others
that we have that are really doing a
good job John
what are you worried that if you do this
too quickly if you lift these
restrictions too quickly the buyers will
start spreading unabated when and how
can you be sure that's not going to
happen well you know we have now a
system and the systems in place and we
have two very very powerful alternatives
that we have to take into consideration
and as I said one of the things that has
really gotten me thinking about this
number one I'm looking at what's going
on you know it's life is fragile and the
economies are fragile but one of the
things is the mortality rate John when
we first started this nobody knew
anything about this particular virus
very very little I mean we started if we
were hearing numbers of 5% I would
that's an astronomical number when the
flu is point zero zero one and two and
three right might one find so 5% would
be an astronomical number now we're
seeing numbers that may be less than one
and that's not including the exercise
that I just went through where many
people don't report so everybody getting
very sick is reporting but nobody
getting you know not very sick that's
why they can be part of that equation so
that just keeps reducing the number so
the mortality rate is a you know that's
a big to me that's a very big factor
when we were hearing three and four
percent remember we had one day where we
thought it was 5% and we're getting a
lot of bad numbers from countries that I
don't know why but we were getting a lot
of bad numbers I do wish again our
relationships very good with China but I
wish they could have told us about this
a little bit sooner you know that but
the mortality rates a big thing for me
because I think we're very substantially
under 1% now that's that's uh
it's still terribly cute though the
whole thing the whole concept of death
is terrible but there's a tremendous
difference between something under 1%
and 4 or 5 or even 3 percent so that's
something that we're learning now and I
think the number may be lower than
people think because of what I've been
saying yeah please president if you
started the tradition